Tucker Carlson is hosting this sit-down
form with the presidential candidates on
the Republican side except for Donald
Trump and the internet is exploding says
the post-millennial because Mike Pence
has apparently committed political
suicide by saying that's not my concern
when asked about U.S cities in reference
to wanting to fund Ukraine now some are
arguing he didn't really mean that since
being taken out of context but the
general idea is that Mike Pence is
talking about how we got to fund and
support Ukraine Tucker says what about
American cities and then Mike Pence said
unfortunately whether he meant it or not
that's not my concern he does go on to
say we want to we want to fix up our
borders and make America better and
things like that but this is interesting
this is the the new way we are having
these political discussions it's not so
much the old school style debate so
we'll talk about that now uh because of
this we're seeing a major swing in
prediction markets with Vivek ramaswamy
skyrocketing and my favorite line yet
the media saying Donald Trump's campaign
pitch is vote for me so we can get
revenge on on the government and
everyone's like okay that sounds pretty
good so we'll talk about that we got a
bunch of other stories too
we got um Snow White and the Seven
politically correct companions who
probably want to talk about those issues
but uh before we do my friends we got a
shout out for Summit Dash
forgery.myshopify.com you can find the
link in the description below Summit
forgery paints quality Miniatures you
can check them out these are these are
really really cool and Summit forgery is
a Tim cast member so we are shouting out
members of timcast every Friday this is
our latest one check the link in the
description below again it's Summit Dash
forgery.myshopify.com and if you're
interested in these figurines they look
really really cool maybe we'll pick some
up but you can support their work thank
you for being a member and we're going
to be shouting out more members in their
work hopefully this is the kind of stuff
we can do that will help boost our
cultural Endeavors and uh Summit forgery
you guys sell a bunch of these and are
able to expand and do a lot more I hope
you guys support each other as well
we got a lot of good work to do and I do
have some updates for you in just a
second but uh uh also don't forget to go
to timcast.com become a member to
support our work directly by clicking
join us and you can watch our members
only uncensored segments and even call
into the show to talk to our guests
that's Monday through Thursday and I
will say additionally just a major shout
out last night
I wish before the show started we had
the idea to pledge all Super Chat
Revenue to the spear Foundation that uh
this is a spear fund I'm sorry Tim
Ballard's organization to try and uh
fund more of the work that he's famous
for which is saving these children but
only at the very last minute did I even
think to offer it someone super chatted
us saying you should give the Super Chat
money to Tim Ballard and I said yes
absolutely we'll do that and then I
realized well hold on asking you guys to
give me money so I can give it to him no
no I'll match it and I did we ended up
in only about five or ten minutes
raising 24
000 in super chats for which 15 minutes
later I wrote a check to Tim Ballard's
Organization for the sum total of fifty
thousand dollars additionally I pledged
11 500 to the Pay It Forward four sound
of freedom and the main reason is
the reason we do this is not about
it it's it's not entirely just about
revenue of course we're capitalists we
like making money we like running our
business and being successful but it's
also about being responsible with the
power bestowed upon us by all of you as
members and uh it is an honor and a
privilege to see the response from so
many of you saying that this is what
your membership is for that we
consistently do the right thing with the
money that you guys give as members and
uh that means a lot I hope we can
continue to do more of that the
overwhelming majority of the money that
we make in this company is reinvested
back into cultural projects working on
new things and doing things like this
shouting out our members and their
projects we uh large contributions to
people who are doing the right thing and
hopefully uh more people who are working
on cultural Endeavors we want to be
sending you guys checks once a month
we're trying to figure out the legal
path to doing it properly we have given
out a decent sum in the five figures in
the past few months to various
individuals who are working on cultural
issues Mo I would say a good portion of
it is protecting children that's been a
big issue for us and for the most part
you just don't hear it because some of
these individuals want it to be private
they don't say hey please shout out the
fact that you gave us money they just
want to keep doing the work we're doing
but I just want you guys to know that it
really means a lot to me that we can
sort of be a vehicle for that for you
that when you guys sign up as members
when you guys watch videos when you buy
cast brew coffee that we are trying to
use all of this to make a positive
difference it's not about us buying
fancy cars or wearing gold chains or
anything like that it's just you know if
there's one thing I could buy and
everyone's saying oh thank you for for
writing this check to Tim Ballard I want
to say first and foremost half of that
was all you the the people in the super
chats half of that was yours so together
we did this but I will tell you if there
is one thing I could buy right now if
someone said hey you want to buy
something you have a choice between a
fancy car or the work of Tim Ballard no
question the work of Tim bout infinitely
more valuable so I just want to say
thank you for everybody who who donated
and watched last night and just to give
you that update uh but let's get to the
show joining us tonight to talk about
this and a whole lot more is Shannon
Bray hello thanks for having me uh who
are you what do you do uh well um
currently I am running for North
Carolina governor that's a my side job
my real job is I work for Department of
Homeland Security and uh helping
um fine-tune some of our government
systems oh that's a tough job it's a
losing job but uh you're a Libertarian
you're running I am North Carolina
absolutely you're gonna get rid of the
IRS or you're gonna well I can't really
get rid of the IRS
yeah yeah but yeah yeah you know I'm
gonna definitely uh wreck wreck the
status quo because you have the
Republicans and the Democrats running
for so long this everything is the same
we're not going to get anywhere with new
uh without new ideas and new politicians
so ultimately I plan on going there with
a wrecking ball and you know making some
serious changes right on well thanks for
hanging out fun we also got Phil Levante
hello everybody my name is Phil Labonte
I am the lead singer of all the remains
anti-communist encounter revolutionary
and my buddy Brett well hello yes my
name is Brett dasovic I am the host of
Pop Culture crisis right here on YouTube
Monday through Friday
happy to be here happy Friday everybody
uh it is Kellen I'm pressing the buttons
today I'm ready to go and you guys are
and I'll just uh add nobody's here today
I'm like where is her everybody's on
everyone's on vacation or on some
Mission people are out doing journalism
Ian's not here he's uh he's out filming
I got a message like Midway through the
show they're like uh can you do the show
tonight I'm like trying to talk and send
the message like yes I can yeah Ian's
not here and uh just an announcement for
everybody I'm gonna be out all next week
Sheamus will be filling in hosting the
show all next week we have a bunch of
really really amazing guests it's going
to be absolutely fantastic and uh
unfortunately for me something I really
really don't want to do I am going to a
sports injury specialist to get uh uh uh
repairs done on my busted up leg so uh
it is what it is nothing I can do about
it but let's uh let's jump into this
first story we got this from the post
millennial internet explodes with memes
after Mike Pence commits career suicide
and interview with Tucker Carlson
following Pence's I'm sorry social media
exploded on Friday after former vice
president Mike Pence spoke with Tucker
Carlson at The Summit in Iowa claiming
that American cities are quote not my
concern while reiterating his support
for the U.S sending more tanks to
Ukraine now uh I want to play this clip
make sure I actually play the full clip
because when I first saw it I felt like
we weren't getting the proper context
and this might not actually be the full
context
so well let's let's just play this clip
and see if we have it then we'll talk
about it
is it planned oh come on Twitter we love
Twitter but not when that happens
all right where's the audio at
right there actually
all right and now I am uh there we go
have enough here we go you are
distressed that the ukrainians don't
have enough American tanks every city in
the United States has become much worse
over the past three years drive around
there's not one city that's gotten
better in the United States and it's
visible our economy has degraded the
suicide rate has jumped public filth and
disorder and crime have exponentially
increased and yet your concern is that
the ukrainians a country most people
can't find on a map who've received tens
of billions of U.S tax dollars don't
have enough tanks I think it's a fair
question to ask like where's the concern
for the United States in that well it's
not my concern
Tucker I've heard that routine from you
before but that's not my concern
I'm running for president of the United
States because I think this country's in
a lot of trouble
I think Joe Biden has weakened America
at home and abroad
and as president of the United States
we're going to store Law and Order in
our cities we're going to secure our
border we're going to get this economy
moving again and we're going to make
sure that we have men and women on our
Courts at every level that will stand
for the right to life and defend all the
god-given Liberties enshrined in our
constitution
anybody that says that we can't be the
leader of the Free World and solve our
problems at home has a pretty small view
of the greatest nation on Earth we can
do both
so before the show we were watching this
the question was is did he literally
just say that American cities are not
his concern and uh Phil you you want to
give your point of view yeah I mean look
I think that he was answering the
previous time that Tucker said was
referring to his concern so Tucker says
you're concerned with Ukraine and giving
money to Crane Etc to Ukraine et cetera
and then Tucker goes on to say there's
uh all these problems at home and then
Tucker uses the phrase uh concern again
I think that Pence was replying to the
first time that he used uh first time
that Tucker used uh concern because then
Pence goes on to talk about the problems
in the United States you know and so
what's the the finality of his his
statement he does talk about Ukraine but
he says if you think we can't do we
can't be the leader of the Free World
then you got a small view yeah it it May
I'm sorry man like I hear what you're
saying and part of me is like maybe we
give him the benefit benefit of the
doubt but uh I I can't do it I'm not
giving I mean I wouldn't vote for his
ass anyway so it doesn't matter but like
I mean but I just who what I mean
seriously so I mean I do think it's
funny that everybody like this is going
viral there's like 50 000 Tweets in the
past a couple hours or whatever and I'm
just like ain't nobody was gonna vote
for this guy in the first place like I
mean he's he's what's he what's he uh
trending at on the on the on predicted
Market uh three cents yeah he's he's
below Nikki Haley this is barely working
it's barely it's only worth talking
about for jokes you know or to you know
to discuss what did people mean
oh my stars and guarders my friends we
just refreshed this to pull up Mike
Pence's numbers the vague ramaswamy is
nearly tied with Ron DeSantis Ron
dropping down now to 15 cents with the
vague skyrocketing the 13-up three with
round down one closing it on second
place these are not polls these are
prediction markets there is a slight
correlation obviously with polling but
these are people making bets on who they
think is going to win and what you're
basically seeing is real time uh I would
say
decentralized computing power as to what
may actually happen so these these
prediction markets have a tendency to be
correct but it's not absolute
what do you think
do you prediction Market or I don't know
Mike Pence I think uh I I think his
statement is the equivalent of going
home telling your wife that uh hey she
didn't mean anything the cashier who
checked me out you know was pretty
professional so it doesn't really matter
what you say after that statement it did
a lot of damage and it doesn't really
acknowledge that I think he's missing
his base right that uh people here
especially people who would already be
more inclined to vote for him than say
someone on the left don't want us in
Ukraine and they don't want us involved
in a bunch of globalist nonsense so he's
missing the mark anyways by talking
about whether the fact that we can do
both people don't want you focusing on
both they want you focusing here at home
right now yeah I don't care if we send
tanks to Ukraine personally
you don't you mean you don't care if
we're doing it as in you don't care to
do no no no I don't care to send weapons
of mass destruction over to a country
it's not like you were saying let them
do it I don't care oh no no no no yeah
yeah thanks for thinking
I don't want my tax dollars fighting
another I'm gonna pull the mic that's
there yes yes yes political suicide well
you know I'm a Libertarian so it's kind
of hard to kill me off that's why I was
like what
so so ultimately I think the big news
yesterday which we only talked about a
little bit Joe Biden calling in reserves
selected reserves and ready reserves to
be sent to Europe yep I'm sorry man
our our culture today
does not support this kind of foreign
intervention it's just for whatever
reason you know what I think it is I
think Ron Paul has a lot to do with it I
think Ron Paul was speaking up in the
late 2000s to a lot of young people
people my age that and not to mention
combined with the anti-war stuff that
was coming uh during the the bush years
and then all of a sudden we're like you
got Democrats saying no war you got
round Paul run as a republican saying no
war hey you know what most of us agree
with that position and don't see a good
reason for U.S intervention overseas we
look back at history we look at what the
founding fathers thought of this and we
say ultimately yeah we shouldn't be
doing it now that's a big problem for
the neocons and the neolibs and people
like Mike Pence who are like we're
leaders of the Free World yeah what he's
really saying is your labor the work you
do every day when you look at your
paycheck and you see that negative
number for income tax it's going to
bombs and guns and tanks and now they're
deploying more U.S Personnel the
reserves that's that's terrifying to be
sent to Europe for this what is it
Atlantic resolve or whatever it's called
why how about our borders how about our
roads and that's exactly what Tucker was
saying to to Mike Pence I got to tell
you this is not his concern if he right
if he couldn't navigate that question
properly and he had to imagine this it's
like you you nailed him he said mean
that much to me to your wife Mike Pence
is basically saying to the face of all
of these people begging to know why our
money is going overseas don't worry it's
somewhat worth it for some vague and
nebulous reason but I'll take care of
the rest too it's exactly as you
described telling your wife don't worry
she doesn't mean anything establishment
Republicans are trying to have their
cake and eat it too they really want to
because there are still Hawks in the
Republican party that want to see the
United States be an expansive uh Power
and they want to see the United States
return to a situation similar to
probably prior to the Iraq War they love
the bush years too yeah you know so I
mean to think that to think that he's
not trying to play to both I think is
probably misguided because like he's got
he has to get Trump's voters you know
hypothetically if he's going to win he
has to convince enough Trump voters and
he has to convince people in the middle
people in the middle are not going to be
compelled by a guy that's that's
essentially a religious uh
fundamentalist or borderline at least of
he's a very religious person I don't
know if you call him fundamentals but
whatever he's very religious I I yeah I
don't think so I think he's like stock
neocon with can with a religious tent
for the purpose of getting votes well
yeah he was the reason why he was such a
good thing for Trump right because he he
colored him and he's supposed to be the
establishment but he was also supposed
to be the guy that made it okay for the
the evangelicals to vote for Trump yeah
that was part of the reason why they
picked him too is because of his his
kind of I mean I had a bunch of friends
that are progressives that were like no
really he tried to shock the gay out of
people when when Pence got elected or
when when Trump got elected so like
there was a whole lot of people that
were afraid of it at least afraid of his
his religious bonafoodies or whatever
um but I he's gotta get the middle and I
don't think that there's any kind of I
don't see a path for him just overall I
don't see how he gets the middle and
satisfies Trump voters and stuff who
want nothing to do with Ukraine and also
satisfies like the fafo morons on on
Twitter you know it's antithetical to
the populist movement that's going on
right now which is very very anti-war
yeah yeah
now a lot of people I I think there's a
lot of people for some reason who like
pants who are like come on you know he
didn't really mean that and it's just
you know my response that is like okay
fine Fair Point whatever if that's what
you want to believe
but in the world of politics let's just
talk superficially
Pence just
he just he just stumbled on a black
sandbag on stage and fell down in front
of everybody it doesn't matter if that's
what he wanted you to believe or even
what he meant it's what matters is what
people take from what you said and the
moment you give them a sound bite that
juicy it doesn't matter what you meant
because history won't remember it he
just fell up the stairs three times in a
row
but I mean look look I mean who likes
Mike Pence what does he have to offer us
but but for real can we can we name any
real policy of of pencils I can tell you
this I know one policy of his more money
and weapons for Ukraine never go into a
room with a woman without your wife
there that's the only policy because I
remember look that's that's like if
you're if you're trying to like if
you're in DC and trying to navigate DC
it's probably not a bad idea it's a very
good idea the pencil rule I remember
though Mike Pence was basically
Whispering you hey dude it's me too era
yeah make sure your wife is with you at
all times and then they attack him for
it for that reason probably yeah because
you know some of these weirdos want to
lie cheat and steal and accuse people of
all sorts of nasty stuff they made they
made a whole big deal about about him
calling his wife mother because because
it was with the it's always are you not
allowed to go to dinner you have mother
and blah blah blah you know and then
Kavanaugh happens and they wonder why it
was such a big deal like yeah shocking I
wanna let's talk about the vague Grandma
Swami because we have this uh we have
this clip here from Tucker as well
Vivek tweeted a clip I want to play for
you guys I'll just play it you know my
parents came to this country with almost
no money
I've gone on to found multi-billion
dollar companies and then people tell me
oh that's because you had privilege
they tell me white privilege it's sort
of weird it's sort of an interesting
it's it's kind of interesting do you
tell them
it's like it's great I I said take the
blindfold off
but the interesting answer is actually
what I do tell them Tucker is that I did
have privilege
I didn't grow up in money
but I had two parents in the house a
mother and a father with a focus on
education and a faith in God and you
know what that is the ultimate privilege
that if I'm going to enjoy that every
kid in this country
ought to enjoy it too thank you
so we have from that clip and the reason
I wanted to play it is I'm going to
refresh for you right now the prediction
markets for the GOP Presidential
nomination which currently has Vivek
ramaswamy at 13 cents Rhonda stands at
15 and Trump at 62 Trump the clear
FrontRunner let's refresh and see where
we're at and the fake has dropped down
by one cent Rhonda centers has gone up
by one cent these things are very much
in flux considering uh these clips are
still going around right now but Vivek
ramaswami is has skyrocketed I mean if
we take a look at this let's go to 90
days in the prediction Market take a
look at this he's jumping he is climbing
the ranks DeSantis is dropping down
rather quickly I do think and again
these are not polls but I think the
people who are tracking the political
landscape who are making bets on what is
gonna uh what the outcome is going to be
I think we're very close to seeing Vivek
ramaswami take second place relatively
soon
I think that like what like what the Vic
said uh at the very end like I'm an
agnostic and I agree with him oh hands
down yeah the clip was fantastic yeah
absolutely
um and nightly privilege that's why he's
advancing in the polls like this because
he speaks I think that he speaks in a
very
um authentic way he doesn't sound like a
politician I don't think or at least he
doesn't come across like a politician to
people because he does sound very
polished but I don't feel like he's
just delivering the the a narrative kind
of line
um and maybe that's my own personal
opinion because I've I'm rather
I find his his
arguments compelling I like listening to
him okay I think all his arguments are
compelling I just everything he is uh he
wants to dismantle the government in
various pieces and I think what he says
a lot is some smart Solutions so I'm
happy that he's getting this out to get
a little bit more name recognition and
I'm surprised that DeSantis has fallen
so much but you know he has so much
negative attention now that I mean with
with Disney whether you're right or
wrong it is anti-cannabis whether that's
right or wrong he's just kind of like
just just driving into the ground
yeah you know look
don't ask me why you know I've got my
opinions on on these things but uh what
I've been saying to many Defender
supporters is just look at the
prediction markets in the polls he's
going down
okay that is not for me wanting to have
and I think he's he's an excellent
leader who really has ear to the ground
on all these issues but I think he's
doing a very terrible job campaign-wise
but even if you think I'm wrong I I just
I'm curious why he's in this decline
if you ignore it it'll only get worse
yeah and his wife's a a a perfect
running mate for him like she's she's
out
um she's well polished and so she she's
adding I think a lot of value but then
at the same time he's obviously crashing
not enough value what do you guys want
uh I would libertarian libertarian well
you're libertarian too man uh Vivek and
RFK made it I I feel like the America
wins to just uh just to voting why RFK
though I'm a big fan of him just uh well
well he's got a big long history of very
authoritarian positions
no I you know here's what I would say
personally
for the Democrat leadership he's the
best they got yeah because with all his
bad policies he's better than all the
rest way better you know so I would love
to see that but and so for me it's kind
of like uh I'm I'm not a big al
libertarian libertarian party kind of
guy I'm actually more like fairly
liberal on the political Spectrum so I
look at an RFK Junior like you know I
think he's really trying to be a
populist he's really trying to reach the
people and uh he's speaking about a lot
of uh current issues that are good so we
we've talked about the power of like a
trump Kennedy ticket but uh I don't want
to ask you about Republicans because you
know you're a Libertarian is there is
there a liberty is there someone you
want to see Run for the libertarian
ticket uh I've seen a couple people who
are running for the libertarian ticket
but yeah I don't quite feel that they're
quite ready isn't on the task huh who's
announced for the Libertarians Chase oh
Chase is from uh from uh Georgia right
yeah yeah okay Chase Oliver yeah uh
Chase Oliver yeah I believe he's
announced
um but yeah I mean I know who he is I
followed him in the Georgia election I
know where he got his Spotlight from
with the whole uh senate election but
you know Shane Hazel did it the year
before I did it same years Shane Hazel
did in North Carolina you know getting
three percent and breaking the uh the
barrier and you know switching the
election it happens every year somewhere
along the line and that's really kind of
what he's writing I don't really know
enough about him I don't agree with them
on
some of the uh qia issues the LGBT you
know yeah which kind of Chase yeah yeah
you know Libertarians tend to really
agree with each other you know yeah you
know a lot of them just say uh yeah yeah
many things aren't good but at the same
time we live in a society where you just
can't run amok
yeah I love I love that Meme though with
groundskeeper Willie and he's like
Libertarians they ruined libertarianism
I mean the the first thing that or the
best way to know that you're an actual
libertarian is another libertarian says
you're not a real libertarian that's
right that's it you know yeah we're
stuck we're getting into it right now I
know a lot of people have said out so
early we're only a few weeks in for a
lot of these candidates but uh this is
where the pickup happens because the
primaries are coming I think what March
yeah of next year so that's gonna be a
big deal it is a very very big deal
historically that Joe Biden is even
facing a primary as the incumbent with
one more term available to him that's
surprising I don't I mean it's I think
that it's surprising that there are
people that are kind of speaking up but
at the same time it's also surprising
that he's actually the president because
he's it's really clear that he's not the
guy running the show he's a puppet yeah
I mean we've got it's run by the the
bureaucracy the existing bureaucracy and
it's not Joe Biden that's making the
calls I mean he's a perfect candidate
for him yeah but not anymore no I mean
in the future because he's not in charge
yeah I wonder if the the reason they ran
Biden was because they feared
prosecution
if uh if Trump won Biden's in trouble
yeah if any other Democrat one Biden
doesn't have any control and may get
thrown to the bus so let's say 2020 you
know let's just say hypothetically
Newsome gets elected for all his faults
and problems
when stories start breaking about
Biden's their corruption say these
stories out of like Politico that came
out you know almost 10 years ago
new you know any other Democrat might be
like look we're not going to sacrifice
the future of our administration because
the mistakes and the problems you
encountered I do think they'd still
probably protect them but he would not
have the power of the presidential seat
to protect himself so I wonder if a
large component was uh oh Trump started
looking into what we were doing in
Ukraine we better
we better get Biden in so we can put an
end to this because that's really was
the big issue Biden did not announce he
was running for president Trump calls
Ukraine and says hey what's up with this
video they then claim in the media
Donald Trump was digging up dirt on his
political opponent as if the only thing
they could have done has been like uh
he's running for office hey you can't do
that you can't you can't look at these
crimes and then now he's got to run for
office you know what I mean and Democrat
media establishment fell in line right
away and started immediately Shifting
The Narrative that direction yeah I mean
that was gonna go as soon as soon as
there was someone that was
establishment approved the the media was
going to go all in anyways uh that that
there wasn't a whole lot of question
about that who's going to be Now is it
going to be like Newsome I mean
overwhelming the prediction markets are
saying Joe Biden
it is interesting seeing the way that
like the fact that there's any
competition at all kind of proves that
if you're not paying close attention you
wonder how that could possibly be
because if you're not paying close
attention you just assume he's doing a
great job you don't know what's actually
going on in the world but if there's any
competition at all it does prove that
there is a bit of a dent in the armor
there and it's hard for the average
person to see but just even hearing
about an RFK if you're somebody that
doesn't pay close attention to politics
I would hope that would at least wake
them up and be like why is there anyone
even questioning this at all you could
actually I guess mention his age would
be a big part of it like a lot of people
even if they're not politically uh
initiated might wonder why is a guy his
age going to be running again Trump's
Trump's very old as well yeah what what
is what is 75 a year younger than Biden
he just doesn't show it no way he's more
than these years yeah yeah he's four
years four or five or four or five like
he will be the same age like he would
have been the same age at the next
election that fighting was when he got
elected and and I think what was RFK
he's 69 or 70. yeah he's like 69 or 70.
we need some younger people I I can
absolutely understand
Vivek yeah if it makes what 38 yeah
maybe 37 he's young uh but Ron DeSantis
too I certainly understand that but I
gotta tell you man if Ron is hurting
this much in the polls and they're not
course correcting I I think that's a
failure of leadership I think I love his
policy I think the reason Iran is is
kind of tanking is because Ron doesn't
have the Charisma people thought that he
was going to have like when he gets onto
the onto the national stage people
aren't like he's not magnetic when he's
on stage he doesn't have the Charisma
he's not he's not like uh uh Barack
Obama he's not Bill Clinton he's not
Donald Trump and those are three people
that had really really significant
Charisma and you there's an argument
that uh that bush had really good
Charisma as well so that could be it but
the a big part of that is people like
the idea that he was more stoic in that
he could be a version of Trump without
out being more bombastic and that was
the top but that doesn't work once you
actually have to come out and speak more
regularly just because that was an
argument doesn't mean that was actually
what the the country was going to feel
yeah you know what I mean so it's and
I'm just saying that this is this could
be I don't know but it would make sense
that the more people
and get exposed to him and hear him
speak at outside of just in the context
of Florida the less they actually like
him when he when he when he felt like
because I'm just I'm not paying as close
attention to that as I as I was before
but when somebody mentioned like his
stance on weed I'm like really really
like even if that is your stance why are
you talking about it now why wouldn't
you hold off and just not mention it
like it just it seems like a
disconnection there are still
Republicans that like that you know well
we can talk about uh the viability of
the Republicans and uh there will be
more developments of course maybe Rhonda
santis will shift some of his campaign
really start to take off it is early
there's a lot of opportunity for him
there but let's talk about the other
side here Joe Biden what's he currently
up to I have this tweet for you from
Andrew at don't walk run he said here's
the raw footage of creepy Joe Biden
trying to sniff slash eat a random
Finnish child I'm gonna play this video
for you
[Music]
hat on the shoulder and he walks away
now the first thing I want to say is
when Biden sees this little kid and
starts doing the Om Nom Nom thing or
whatever and they're all laughing
if this was a family member and being
endearing to a grandchild I might be
like you know whatever but here's the
bigger issue for one this is a strange
guy doing that what are you doing to
this kid man that's inappropriate but
also it's it's the double dip
the double that watch this clip I'm
gonna go slow after after he moves back
he goes back in and does this very weird
sniff right there look at that slow
motion slow motion and reverse the first
one you can say oh he's just being old
you know family Uncle Joe Grandpa Joe
whatever and then the kid looks
distressed look at the kid's face and he
goes in for an extra sniff
right there
sniff what's with the sniff
yo I I
he's sniffing sniffing Joe and he
promised he'd stop you remember this yes
well he doesn't I guarantee you he does
not remember making that promise that
explains it a man needs a leash yeah
like just imagine when he gets so near a
kid being any of the people that have to
work on that campaign anytime he has to
go out anywhere near children and
they're just like you think Usher's a
menace yes uh well Usher maybe a menace
Biden's a worse Menace that is for sure
so Joe Biden
he you know he goes out early a few
years ago and he's sniffing women and
and squeezing them and yeah like adults
too right yes yes and then everyone was
like hey yo joe you got to stop he comes
out and he's like I'm sorry I'm just you
know I'm it's an oh I'm an old man we
used to do this stuff I'm willing to bet
when that happened
things like this he goes back and he
gets into the vehicle or whatever and
they're alive 88 miles an hour yeah no
they go Joe you need to stop stiffing
kids and he goes I'm an old man I got
very few things left in life give me
this one wait who is it when they're
like I'm not a pervert I'm Italian
that's it like that was Cuomo yeah is
there and is there a Biden Brewing I'm
I'm a Delaware man and then Cuomo went
on to post a video of all the time he he
inappropriately touched me the thing
dude I'm the thing is I know there were
women that were like I'm fine with it
I'm fine with it because I know
personally no more than one woman that
said to me yeah I mean it's it's Cuomo
he's fine I don't care that he I'm like
really wow that is insane to me I mean
come on look the average woman they see
Joe Biden and they're Fanning themselves
indeed I mean come on he's a he's a
regular
Humphrey Bogart I'm sure Tara Reid has
nothing but he's a regular Hugh Hefner
who's that who's a celebrity from that
era that would would have been
considered
one of the first uh Fitness guys yeah
super ripped you know ladies they let
they loved him you know he was very in
shape yeah Tara Reid would beg to differ
yeah about yeah I know yeah the Joe
Biden phone call yeah you got to make
that like the campaign thing because
they talk about how Trump can't get
Suburban women votes because he's like
Grody like lecherous or whatever just
okay well you know play the Biden game
just just you know you you go to a voter
and be like I want you to imagine Joe
Biden he comes up from behind slides his
hands onto your back I'm already done
gives you a little squeeze and then
how do you feel would you like to vote
for him violated
yeah would you like to vote for him I've
never felt more victimized in my life
I I just
I mean it's been years and here we are
once again with a viral video
everybody's sharing it of Joe Biden
sniffing kids yeah well honestly though
like this is only going to get worse
because he's not getting it cognitively
he's not getting better and they're
getting rid of all the drugs in the
white house so he won't be able to close
I doubt they're getting rid of it
they've already made no they're not
getting rid of the drugs they're making
the problems go away so they're not
making the drugs go away I know you
always let them happen to them remember
when they said that the drugs may have
been from a journalist that was actually
a warning to the journalists who
reported on it the Secret Service is
they look at the reporter report and
they're like maybe it belonged to a
journey
the story goes away yeah that's exactly
what happened at least that's what I
wanted wait wait could you imagine like
come on Joe Biden is what 80 years old
now yeah we are gonna get to a point you
know you know they say like old people
are racist because I just don't care
anymore or something like that like what
happens when we get to that point where
they can't control Joe because he's just
so old he just doesn't care and he's
like oh
you know Mike's life expectancy was two
years ago
I got I got nothing you know you can't
hold you got no leverage sounds like
he's on this floor of the senate in 1996
or something they're gonna cut them off
and then do the um what's that Bernie
thing where they just kind of spoke yeah
bring his body around oh we're gonna
burn it but look look
Joe Biden with they're gonna go to him
and say like look Joe we want you to
make these moves like I'm 80. I'm past
my life expectancy and they're like well
you have a son don't you he's like oh
are you kidding me you think I'm gonna
respond to a threat to that guy they
have to withhold ice cream that's the
only thing they have over it no no
the other way around positive
reinforcement they say okay okay fine
yeah what if we get you some talking
dogs and he's like
all right
we'll get you some Ben and Jerry's and
we'll have a clown feed it to you no but
but in all seriousness there's got to
come a point where Joe Biden just there
was that video where I think he was
campaigning in like 2020
and some guy asked him a question and he
just snaps and that's gone like what
and I think that's because he's just
like I don't care I'm so done and uh and
he's in this position I I feel like
you know a lot of people have wondered
like why would they try and replace him
in the primary
isn't Joe the Deep State like wouldn't
he just step down voluntarily if they
really wanted someone else and I'm like
yeah maybe he's just gone Rogue maybe
he's just like I'd do whatever I want I
don't care you got nothing over me maybe
they have a schedule and they just told
him wait just hold out until we announce
blah blah blah or whatever you know and
I really don't think that he has a
significant amount of input I really
feel like he's like he's like you know
handlers do the whole deal well that's
what they love about it right yeah and
every time they think about getting rid
of them they look at Kamala they're like
a couple more kids is fine we'll we'll
keep going it's fine look look at this
this is the prediction market for the
Democrats Joe Biden's at 65 cents he is
the sitting president and incumbent and
there's people a lot of them 35 who
think yeah he ain't gonna win Gavin
Newsom you know what it is though which
you got to understand about these
prediction markets there's also a value
bet in that look if I spend 21 cents on
a share of Gavin Newsom that's a that's
nearly a five times return if he gets
the nomination
that's really what it's about I still
think it's fair to consider it should be
100 for Joe Biden the fact that
predicted decided to make a contract on
if he would even be the nominee says
Allah he's the freaking guy that saved
democracy didn't he he came and swooped
in and said yo I'm saving democracy from
the Donald Trump and mega Americans no
like he's the one who was was like the
Saving Grace for America right but I
like that saving democracy from Trump
supporters
basically saying like removing them from
the Democratic 100 that's the point like
that like I talk about like maoism and
stuff a lot like that's what he when
they say our democracy the people that
are the deplorables are not included
they are not part of their democracy
that is a distinction between people
that support them and people that don't
that's the same kind of crap that
mounted too malwood it was saying in
Chinese but it was the same thing it was
our democracy because they use the same
phrases they use democracy and they talk
about it but under with their
understanding you're it's not a full
democracy unless everybody has an equal
voice not just you know everyone gets a
vote well so I feel like it's the same
thing I feel like what they're basically
saying is our democracy refers to us all
in agreement with each other yes you
guys are not in agreement so we must
remove you from the process 100 that's
why they also laugh at the idea when you
point out the fact that it's not a
democracy that you do live in a
constitutional republic and there are
things that that entails and then they
laugh at that because that's not
actually what they're talking about yep
yep
absolutely like that's that is the the
line that they're using there's so much
stuff again Lynn James Lindsay from uh
new discourses he did a podcast on this
and he went through a speech that Mao
did and that it was translated to
English and then he said look this right
here what that Mao is saying is the
exact same thing that Kamala Harris
means when she says this this right here
that Mao was saying is the exact same
thing when you translate it to English
that the that the uh that Joe Biden is
saying here so there's this when when I
say that there are communist influence
throughout all of our government it goes
through the bureaucracy all the way up
through actual like DSA members but all
the way to the the presidency there are
some people that repeat the things
knowingly that they're communist things
and there are some people that repeat
them without knowing that they're
repeating communist propaganda but
there's a ton of communist propaganda in
the media right who is it in the media
and in the government who is the CNN
reporter that like they had him change
his shot and there was like a picture of
Mao in his wall do you remember that
like it's in there just like ignore that
that didn't or they they just expect you
to not know
you're looking for yeah
he's known for plagiarism so maybe he's
consciously going through and reading it
thinking it's Chinese nobody will know
he's like hey there's my guys
I love this story this is a meme ABC
news says Trump's unprecedented campaign
speech campaign pitch Trump's
unprecedented campaign pitch elect me to
get revenge on the government Mega baby
yeah right I love it because they write
this unironically and
Libertarians post-liberals Trump
supporters are screen grabbing it and
posting the Chad meme with just yes yes
yes that's the most compelling thing
I've ever heard a politician say in my
life yes get revenge on the government
sign me up look at this Donald Trump has
told supporters not to just see him as a
candidate but as quote your retribution
yes Milo said this was on the show said
this he said in his comeback bed for the
White House the former president twice
impeached but twice acquitted now twice
indicted haha has vowed that if
re-elected he will wield his power to
personally remake parts of the federal
government to a degree that historian
mark up the Grove said was unprecedented
Trump has promised to hamstring
perceived enemies including the doj
which is currently investigating him and
Target Republican Boogeyman like
President Republican bogeyman like
President Joe Biden it sounds like
they're saying Joe Biden's a republican
he's swore in June to a point of special
prosecutor to go after the bidens
okay good and that he would totally
obliterate the Deep State
um not hearing any insult or negativity
you know referring to a conspiratorial
view of how the government operates
this is the final battle either they win
or or we win he said the Libertarians
just got out libertarian by The Bump
Stop guy what are you doing
well come on look look yeah I mean uh I
think it's an excellent I think it's an
excellent speech but what's his policy
actually going to be how is he really
going to do it
chainsaw but is he gonna take out the
IRS is he going to take out doe what are
you actually going to do does Santa said
he was going to do that didn't he he
talked about Department of Education
yeah oh education education which is I
mean I love it yeah
if if all Donald Trump at this point has
is they have slighted me and I will fire
them I'll be like okay take my vote I
mean fire them all I like can
Libertarians disagree I mean you know
fire them all and I don't think that he
would be entirely successful but it
would be a lot of fun to watch him try
yeah I think he'd be successful at this
point I mean I I I I just want to stress
I don't think he did a perfect job at
his first time I didn't vote for him in
2016. I think he did some these
moderately good things with in terms of
foreign policy I really liked and uh
some culture War issues he was very late
in the game too so he's not he wasn't my
first choice a your guy said DeSantis
because DeSantis has been on top of the
the game when it comes to uh culture War
issues but Donald Trump comes out and
he's like don't know don't care I want
revenge I'm gonna fire everybody and I'm
like I see fire in his eyes
that's all I can ask for well it's not
necessarily about the American people
it's his revenge but we all may benefit
from him that's right and I mean like
considering how selfish and narcissistic
the guy is I want him to make it
personal because that's way more of a
motivator than me right like I'm not
Donald Trump doesn't give a crap about
me if I'm standing on the sidewalk and
there's like
you know a guy behind me and I see Trump
barreling full speed power walking all
angry I'm getting out of the way right
I'm Gonna Be Alive oh I'm not gonna
don't let me stand in your way sir and
that may mean you are not getting what
you want but the guy behind you turns
out to be a Mugger that was after you
and so I'm like I'll take it if you're
in a war zone and you're at your enemy
gets hit with Friendly Fire thumbs up
like that's cool like they're they if
they're gonna smoke each other take each
other out fine if Donald Trump wants to
go in there and actually make Cuts go
get him isn't it funny how terrified the
corporate press is though
why are journalists so scared that
someone would fire bureaucrats access
because they're friendly with it with
the bureaucrats now and because they get
they have their personal email addresses
and their personal home phone numbers
and sometimes they get Scoops so it's
all about access one of the hardest
things I think would be if he's talking
about getting rid of the deep State it's
it's the unelected officials right you
can fire you can fire all the heads of
departments you want but all of those
heads of departments have trained people
under them who think like they do who
they've groomed for those positions
farther up so it's not just getting rid
of whoever you're talking about whether
you're talking about CIA all of these
departments there's going to be somebody
that's going to come in there because
it's not like this is one generation of
a problem this is multi-generational and
it will take more than one president if
you're going to actually turn things
around if this is my opinion and I don't
know for sure what the legality is of
the of the government of the federal uh
the president actually getting rid of
cabinets that's what I'm saying like
what does that mean mean getting rid of
abolishing like we're not so when I say
get rid of I mean abolish at the cabinet
level so the whole department from the
the seat on the cabinet all the way down
to the you know ground enforcers of
whatever Department we're talking about
whether it be HUD whether it be the
department of energy which I don't know
that we can do that because the nuclear
stuff but still uh the department of the
Interior dot uh IRS uh well that's part
of the treasury so that would be a
little different but like you know
there's plenty of stuff that he could
that he could get get rid of as the
executive and just be like get out here
in the in the Justice Department alone
he could do stuff with the F get rid of
the stuff of the FBI by executive order
he can get rid of stuff with the ATF by
executive order because if if I
understand correctly I could be wrong
but I that's the way that I believe
because he is the executive of the or he
is the executive he can get rid of stuff
in the Department of Justice so like
that would be a great place to start FBI
and and ATF and stuff but the more that
he's looking to cut whoever's looking to
cut the most that's who I'm behind the
second most Cuts is the second person
I'm behind like that it's that simple
like I don't give a crap about any of
their personalities who's going to
shrink the federal government the most
because right now it's the biggest
government in human history so don't
tell me we can't cut Trump should go to
libertarian rallies and be like I'm
gonna fire everybody he shouldn't he
should have gone to pork fest and
they're gonna seriously yeah and they're
gonna and they're gonna be like I really
don't want to vote for bump stock Donnie
but yeah if he really is gonna fire
these people and like you can see the
fire in his eyes and the want for
Revenge I mean you might actually get it
yeah that's that's that's like the
difficult libertarian position I guess
you know even Dave Smith was like
there's some foreign policy stuff he did
that was good and it's like man but also
like the didn't they also question why
didn't you pardon Assange why didn't you
yeah like had he done that I would have
really liked to have seen that it felt
like a lot of that stuff the pardons at
the end a lot of that stuff felt very
performative of and there was more
important real change that he could have
made through that stuff that would have
been even on the way out would have been
good for his re-election campaign
Snowden and Assange has he done that he
would have won the hearts of a lot of
Libertarians just because of that move
we did have Don Jr on and he did say
it's time we do pardon Assange and
Snowden and uh I'm not even as bullish
on Snowden to be honest you know Snowden
is is like a middle of the road thing
for me uh Assange is no-brainer Assange
shouldn't be charged at all he's an
international journalist who is wrongly
charged with with deep BS they falsely
accuse him of abusing women not true now
they're accusing me of Espionage
literally a journalist what does he do
he gets information he publishes
information Snowden was a leaker Snowden
took information gave it to journalists
without knowing what it was there's an
argument to be made that it was so good
what he did exposing things like xq
score and what you know NSA spying that
it's high time we say look you know no
more Exile come on home man like we we
are happy we got information
but the thing about Snowden it's like
you know the big issue is he did not
know what he was giving out he knew some
of it but he just took a bulk thing I'm
not all about encouraging that I like
whistleblowers I think people should
expose darkness and Corruption
but we have Security in this country for
a reason like I like this country I like
the fact that we we defend ourselves you
know you can't just leak everything but
uh that being said even Don Jr said I
think it's it's high time we do pardon
him that doesn't mean uh uh uh Trump
senior would do it but it does show that
there is at least a sphere of influence
in the Trump world that is starting to
be like
let's roll with it I do think the reason
Trump wanted Assange brought to the U.S
was because Assange knows things
pertaining to the clintons The
Establishment neolibs neocons and Trump
wanted that information and Assange
would not give it up because Assange has
integrity and he is a journalist and he
protects his sources
so I think that was a strong component
for Trump he knew he's like this guy's
got information we need and won't give
it up
I also think that the the Intel agencies
are a big part of why we need to to pair
back right it's like you just you can't
you cannot do a lot of this unless we
figure out a way to limit the influence
of these Intel agencies who are
essentially responsible to no one
accountable to no one you're right but
the information that the that we're
worried about the Intel agencies
collecting is the information that we're
voluntarily giving to all the social
media companies and Google and stuff so
I get it you're right and I would I I
don't know what the way or the best way
to prevent the government from just
subpoenaing it because the these
companies are just throwing the
information at the feds as soon as the
feds ask they're just like yeah yeah
because again access because of favor
with the most powerful government ever
so I don't know what the right way to
fix it is but they've already got the
information you know your social media
companies and stuff like that they all
have the information out there so it for
the feds it's just a matter of sending
the subpoena we've given all of our
stuff up but it also seems like the
focus isn't is increasingly more
domestic right yeah we are not focusing
overseas the way we used to we're
focusing a lot more on domestic
terrorism with Patriot front and other
such Federal organizations uh
like it just it just feels like that's
where a lot of those cuts would need to
come but it's going to be very hard to
do that because they're so burrowed into
our government well the whole Patriots
act itself you know it's called The
Patriot Act because it sounds awesome
but all it is is oh that too as I said
Patriot front Patriot front uh another
group you know domestic terrorists and
that's a big part of our Focus here in
this country now is they're using that
as a weapon against regular Americans
who are not idiots like Patriot runs
that's the federal theater kid exactly I
want to pull up this year tweet we have
a big story we didn't get into it
yesterday because of course we're
talking about uh sound of freedom but
Twitter is now going to be paying it's
uh it's pers personalities who generate
a certain amount of uh Impressions
basically Twitter will operate in a
similar way that YouTube does that if
you produce content that gets views and
those views deliver ads you get a cut of
these ads I was pleasantly surprised
rather abruptly to get a pop-up on
Twitter that said they were paying me
about six grand and I'm like I don't
even I don't even do anything like like
I barely even use Twitter but I want to
pull up this tweet from Brian
krasenstein the uh I think Brian has
been on a terror lately with some
excellent tweets and this one is very
good for those that are familiar he is a
liberal personality but check out this
one this is good he tweets the most
entertaining outcome is the most likely
outcome I believe it was Elon who said
that wasn't it or is that a quote from
somebody else that's musk yeah he
answered that and he goes blocked by
Trump on Twitter in 2018. unblocked by
Trump on Twitter in 2019 banned from
Twitter in 2019 unbanned by Elon in 2022
made 25
000 from Twitter in 2023 at this rate
I'll be CFO of Twitter by 2024 and
Trump's VP by 25.
so uh here's what's funny about this
story
of course we'll get into the Twitter
stuff but uh Taylor Lorenz you know
where your lover wrote far right Twitter
influencers first on Elon musk's
monetization scheme I love it Andrew
Tate I am pretty sure that Brian
krasenstein the liberal Biden voter made
more money than edutate and the
krasensteins because it's his brother as
well even pointed out that between them
they made way more money than some of
these other personalities and Taylor
Lorenz is calling it far right and
omitting them from the story I far-rated
before we came I came over to here for
the uh the show I went to the gym and I
was doing cardio oh geez I'm sure that
JoJo from jurors and Brooklyn dad
are doing fine on Twitter as far as
monetization but yeah uh they don't get
it from Twitter though they get it from
the DNS yes exactly right uh did you say
Kellen earlier that you said that uh
that um Taylor Lorenz was offered to box
with Ashley Sinclair I think Ashley
Sinclair offered yeah it's never going
to happen
we've had him on the show before but uh
Brian responded to Taylor's Taylor
lorenza's article for those for those
are not familiar with this context
Taylor Lorenz is a notoriously bad
journalist who has written a false and
misleading stories
so in response to saying far right
Twitter influencers make money he said
you might be reading the watch and Post
article by Taylor Lorenz and be thinking
but Brian krasenstein made twenty four
thousand dollars from Elon he's not far
right all I can say is I work out and I
said I warned you Brian Brian he posted
a video of him working out and I said
you're going to become conservative
that's how that's how it goes start
going to the gym
yeah and then Ed crescentstein uh his
brother also criticized this very
heavily saying it was factually
incorrect noting that there were
right-wing personalities posting this
but that they had actually made more
money than a lot of people this is the
media's game what happened is threads
comes out by Instagram it sucks it's
horrible Elon then launches as
prescribed in February that there would
be rev sharing like YouTube does and
other social media platforms do
Instagram and Facebook do and now
they're acting like it is a big scheme
to bribe people to stay on the platform
and they're acting like it's the far
right so let me get this straight does
YouTube bribe people is BR yeah all of
these liberal personalities and leftists
stop they refuse to pay for Twitter they
stop using Twitter and then when the
people who actually use the platform get
paid they go aha Elon Musk is bribing
people it's like dude the crescentsteins
used the platform stuck to the platform
they're liberals they made money
at any rate this is a very very big deal
in that there is now a viable platform
for monetization outside of YouTube
look I I tweet random nonsense I have
1.7 million thousand to it I don't know
why but thank you for following me on
Twitter now I kind of know why now I'm
like oh I should post Clips onto Twitter
I should I should post content there we
should simulcast the stream or do
something like that on Twitter because
now there's an opportunity to break the
censorship market and shatter the the
the the censorship
get all those hot takes you've been
saving up forever and just start
dropping them one by one so you can
start making money I mean the the thing
is you I don't know what it if they've
got like special rates for people that
produce content that's exclusive for
Twitter or what the deal is going to be
but you know a place like this produces
plenty of content to put up on on the
old Twitter machine you know I think
it's awesome over the last few weeks
you've seen with The Young Turks uh I
can't remember her Anna Anna and now
with the crassons teens I don't want to
call it a red pilling because I don't
think it's quite that but they're kind
of seeing just how crazy the cult is
right because they got paid from Twitter
they're right wing now like come on man
so I hope the crashing scenes kind of I
think they know I think they realize how
kind of extreme the left can be at times
and I I think definitely Anna knows from
The Young Turks but it's been awesome to
witness you know from like a back seat
kind of perspective over the last few
weeks because she does not want to be a
birthing person yeah no no bonus holes
that's why everyone's upset
so yeah
[Music]
I heard it that way yeah that one ends
up in the chat very often that one ends
up in the chat very often when you're on
when you're online
I mean I don't blame her you know but
we're just seeing like the mob online
come after the crassensteins and The
Young Turks and it's over nothing I mean
seemingly nothing just having a
difference of opinion we had a uh on the
culture War this morning we had uh two
drag queens one was a more leftist drag
queen one was a not really left or right
just an uh older drag queen the uh Kitty
demure and maybe a girl were the two
drag queens and uh Kitty uh the drag
queen's name I suppose uh I believe it's
a kitty I could be wrong but I was
saying look you know kids should not be
in these things these are for adults
these are nightlife these are nightclub
things these are party things and uh the
leftist was saying uh more otherwise
that was basically the argument but the
interesting thing about it was the uh
the cult-like ideology that persists in
the left's view and there was a moment
in the show the reason I bring this up
is that I think the the drag queen the
leftist may have stumbled into something
inadvertently which could cause problems
for them I criticized the book
genderqueer
at the end of the show saying
conservatives have criticized this book
without reading it and they should read
it and uh many and you know post-liberal
thinkers and anti-work people have
criticized the book without reading it
they should because they highlight this
book genderqueer as having graphic
images that shouldn't be shown to kids
that's correct but the book is about
this individual this authors deep abuse
and Trauma growing up from abusive
parents being forced to reuse menstrual
products for for days on end to the
point where they smelled horribly were
pulled out of class not being able to
read till 12 having to uh go about their
you know relief business outside
and uh maybe said thank you for that in
response I don't think that thank you
will fly with the cult on the left and
that I think whether I'm right or wrong
my point is just my perception of it
there is a clear fall in line say
whatever you're supposed to say no
matter what it is no matter how silly
silly it is
or else whereas whatever this faction is
it's conservative liberal libertarian
people disagreeing on a ton of issues
but like kind of just being chilled with
each other
yeah I get called bigot by other
Libertarians just because of my stance
on that particular issue just because
you're a Libertarian just because I'm a
Libertarian yeah but what is what is up
with that I mean let's talk about that
because um
you know Joe Jorgensen and it was I
think it was 2020 right tweeted that uh
that that cult worship line it is not it
is not enough to be to not be racist we
must be actively anti-racist which is
basically a cult Mantra it's like
effectively a a neo-marxist prayer to
see a Libertarian tweet we must do
something was kind of hilarious to me
like we all must do this things like I
thought we were all about individual
liberty and responsibility I'm curious
your thoughts on that element of the
libertarian party and those ideas yeah
I'm uh I'm all about the individual
um and not necessarily the party itself
I was a Libertarian well before I even
knew what the party was when I was kind
of looking for my identity you know back
when uh McCain and Sarah Palin were were
running and I just didn't like any of my
options so I mean I adopted ideology
just because it's it it makes sense to
me you know you don't hurt other people
you don't take people's stuff and you
just kind of mind your own business and
live your life but you know now you have
the government coming in and ultimately
trying to make decisions for you both on
the left and the right one tries to to
police Your Existence and the other one
does now the same thing and tries to
take your money along with it and you
know that they're they're redefining
Society now in a culture war that
doesn't even seem to make sense to me
um and they're drawing lines in the sand
that you know I've talked to people in
the L the G the B and the T communities
and they're all in agreement right and
then you have the qias uh and I don't
even know what the inea stand for but
intersex right and uh queer intersex and
asexual but there's more than that
there's two two s i uh you know two
Spirits right yeah and yes and then like
there's a bunch of other letters that go
into it but I mean I feel like with with
the T right I I feel like a lot of that
is like with the body dysphoria uh and
the and the in the middle aspects where
the Q is more just how I feel today well
so here's the interesting thing I mean I
mean the the the T does encompass what
uh the drag queen earlier was saying is
Trans non-binary in which people will be
gender fluid that's how they describe it
boy you're about to find out oh yeah but
here's what I see with the the progress
pride flag it is at one point it was a
rainbow flag to symbolize you know the
LGBT community then they added these
Stripes to it then they added a triangle
to it then added a circle to it they're
basically
it's like The Horde in World of Warcraft
you guys know that what that reference
is yep it was these various bands of uh
fractured cultures that came together
and so the idea behind that flag is
aggrieved groups forming under one
Banner they don't necessarily make sense
it does not make sense to have a gay
pride flag that includes black people
well because not all black people are
gay I mean the the insinuation that this
is a pride flag for gay LGBT Pride
and all black and brown people are a
component of that doesn't seem to make a
lot it's it's not the same thing have
people started I feel like people
started calling it the progress flag do
you feel like that's I believe it's
called the progress pride flag okay
maybe this is all just a really good
plot from a flag maker who just wants to
sell you a new flag every couple of
years because they have to keep adding
things to it constantly it's just all
about oppression it's called the
progress pride flag and so it's got uh
uh it's now got black brown sky blue
pink white a yellow triangle and a
purple circle it's basically just
putting symbols of aggrieved groups into
one flag what's the purple circle uh I
believe that's it could be asexual okay
is there a white diamond maybe it could
be interesting nothing wise there's a
white stripe
but we know what group is not included
and that's well no no so the progress
Pride flag does have a white triangle on
it and that's because uh uh the what is
this okay so the progress Pride flag out
right here the largest component of it
is a white triangle and that's because
they all uh agree that uh they think
white people are the most powerful and
you know of course they want to make
sure they're represented perfectly on
their flag I'm kidding by the way
it is true there's a giant white
triangle on the flag maybe that's for
the white women there's no there's no
explanation for the white triangle is
it's really caring I mean maybe that's
where the power of character is stored
let me look this up but what what are
the colors what do they mean okay so
let's see the progress pride flag and I
pulled this thing I pulled up on my
phone for whatever reason said what do
the rainbow stripes mean red is life
oranges healing yellow is sunlight green
is nature blue is harmony purple is
Spirit okay what do the triangles mean
the light blue light pink and white
section represent transgender yeah the
black and brown stripes represent
marginalized communities of color the
black stripe represents those who have
been lost to AIDS
holy wait what really
that is it I feel like that's deeply
racist and to say that the black stripe
for black people is the aid stripe is
horrifyingly racist I think the brown
stripe is wow people of color and the
black stripe is fur no no no look I'm
I'm look I don't know this is
kansascity.com this is a looks like a
um it's so annoying oh these websites
are terrible this is a Kansas City Star
and it says that the black stripe
represents AIDS and black people
I'm not I'm not exactly let me pull this
out this is shocking to me I mean
I feel like depending on where you go
They're gonna have a different
definition for this flag it's part of
what Tim was saying how it's like uh War
of Warcraft World of Warcraft how it's
all these random groups under one Banner
look look look it's perfectly stupid
this is the Kansas City Star News Guard
certified 92.5 out of 100 June 20th 2022
what does it mean I I will I will scroll
that's exactly what I was reading I
can't believe they actually wrote this
it says the black and brown stripes
represent people of color and then it
says the black stripe also represents
people who've lost two AIDS they're
quite literally saying that the black
stripe represents black people and AIDS
victims in the same category that is
deeply racist
there's that coveted stripe like what
about the other diseases
yes but but that obviously there isn't
there is when it comes to Pride there is
a question over AIDS and and epidemic
and what happened in the 80s and Reagan
and all that stuff I can understand them
wanting to include it
but I didn't know that they were making
one strike for black people and AIDS
victims I feel like I I that sounds
deeply deeply offensive yeah I mean the
thing is they don't think about this
kind of stuff I I really don't think
they put a whole lot of thought into it
I think that it's like like throwing
stuff against the wall like throwing
spaghetti into the wall see what sticks
well why did they even have to do a race
the black and brown to begin with are
you serious because they're marginalized
uh and so have you turned on the
television the past 10 years have you
looked at a newspaper do you think the
average person who flies the flag would
be able to tell you like if you gave him
a quiz you gave them like a thing and
like it's got a little box there you
have to mention like can you point out
what this one means what this one means
what this one means do you think the
average person would be able to tell you
what any of those stripes yeah because
they're teaching it in our school
systems now it's like a little fill-in
graph it's like a coloring sheet you
have to fill it in and know what it
means no it's like that Tick Tock of the
the little boy who's with his mother and
he oversights lgbtqia like it's
lightning fast and second nature to them
now like just like we recite the
alphabet it is well it's able to do the
acronym we even have to do the shows
like lgbtq plus plus eight yeah yeah
it's like you get down you're like your
brain just kind of goes numb and your
eyes go wide and you're just like
because you had to say it so many times
wow this is stonewallsociety.com says
that the victory over AIDS flag is the
black stripe
so like quite literally they
it's crazy because when I was growing up
like like in the 90s like they were very
adamant that aids was not a LGBT
disease AIDS was something that
everybody had to worry about AIDS was
something that you know Etc et cetera
Etc and then now it's like oh well this
is a a personal part of our story and
our history and it's like
were you joshing before
like what why is it that like back you
know again I mean I think that I think
it's it's
I think it's a fairly common knowledge
that the that aids as a a disease is
mostly found in the Gabe Community it's
very it's it's rarely found outside I
don't think mostly is the correct word I
think that in the United States it
largely impacts the gay community but uh
I don't I don't think it's true to say
that it is mostly no mostly I mean it's
very different from um largely affecting
okay yeah all right well fair enough
then uh because I don't know
particularly but it does you know speak
to
it's it's certainly saying something
when they're like hey this is something
that impacts our community
uniquely which is what they're saying
as far as I I gotta be honest I I am I
am I am shocked to discover that uh they
actually did that
but I'm not surprised to hear that
they're racist I mean I I firmly believe
the Democrats are deeply racist have
always been racist have never stopped
being racist and they they always play
this game of oh but the party switched
and I'm like dude I don't care about
political parties I don't know nothing
about that all I know is y'all are
racist I mean you the the political
party that is largely focused on race
and continues to make race a topic is
probably the one you can safely say is
racist the one that says hey we don't
want to focus on this Stuff
Etc is probably not particularly racist
that just seems to be fair you know
obvious to me
it's because you're trying to keep your
power in office there by not talking
about it
man that's crazy yeah you Republican oh
God all right here we go you guys ready
for this one from the National Review
Secret Service found marijuana twice at
the White House in 2022. okay I mean
does that bother me it's legal there
right well not inside the Federal
Building no but like
at what point do we say come on it
depends on if it was like Edibles or if
it was okay
we know I I think we get it all right
someone just needs to Joe can you ask
your son just maybe no if he's gonna if
he's gonna Smoke by you know if it's
gonna be him like can you just clean it
up and just not get caught I really
don't think that uh Hunter Biden is
smoking much weed personally I really
think that it's that it's amphetamines I
think that it's cocaine maybe but I mean
if if he is if he was getting off of
that stuff man I wouldn't be surprised
if he was like well this one's not so
bad sometimes it's also funnier than
maybe Joe's just not senile and old
maybe he's just super stoned all the
time that would be that's actually a way
funnier story no because if that was the
case then he would have actually
descheduled it like he said he was going
to do instead of just waving it off and
it never happened first thing he does in
office is make it legal so he can have
it right there right I mean the
executive order is the way uh the way I
would have rolled as president like
Hunter you're free baby I think they're
trying to plant it on Biden and he just
keeps leaving random places
right so they're like we got to get them
out there's no chance in 24 so they keep
getting all these different drugs hoping
that secret service will find it on him
but Biden's just not with it so he just
keeps leaving it places like outside the
Situation Room they're like we really
don't know who it belongs to because
it's Joe's hunter gets a coffee thing
here right maybe you get Joe your coffee
and uh he'll wake up I just gotta say
you know our coffee is the best coffee
Appalachian nights the best coffee
everyone agrees if Joe had that coffee
right now the country being a way better
way better way better maybe Afghanistan
would have been Flawless
maybe that's the commercial we do we
have like you see Joe Biden but only
from from behind and he's like stumbling
and we show all the clips of him stomach
falling and then it's like people in
suits being like quick quick and they
pull the bag of cast brew coffee and
then you see Biden stumble in and
there's like a camera shaking and he
grabs the coffee sips it and then all
sudden stands up right and he's like I'm
ready man fixes him fixes them right up
perfect yeah I think you should or we
can do one where someone keep like Ian
travels back in time and keeps pouring a
glass of Casper coffee for Joe right
before these major moments and then
everything just goes right
it's like preparing for the Afghan
withdrawal and then Ian's just like
pouring the cup of coffee and he slides
it out there saving the world one cup of
Casper with them right before the
debates
you know uh in all seriousness serious
uh seriousness though
I don't really care for a pot I'm not a
fan of it I think it's very bad for
people I think a lot of people are like
ah it's no big deal it should be legal
and all this stuff and I'm like well
okay I'm fairly libertarian on stuff I
don't care what you do with your life
but I think wheat is pretty bad for you
I think to all the people I knew growing
up growing up and you know the ones that
were smoking pot all the time did not do
nearly as well as the ones who did not
and so you know whatever I think that's
why you say actually South Park said it
the best Randy Marsh said son it's not
that it's gonna kill you or do anything
to you it's that it makes you okay with
being bored and then when you're older
you'll find you're not good at anything
so that's a reason why you shouldn't do
he's like okay thanks Dan but uh that
being said it is not legally allowed in
the white house and there is a drug
problem in the white house right now I I
have questions you know we talk about a
two or three tiered justice system
come on man
come on
oh there's at least three tiers there's
the broken the not broke yeah right and
then and then you can talk about the
whether Trump's on a different level
than Biden or whatever but yeah I'm not
included in any of that uh and I I'm
supposed to have a white privilege yeah
right so uh they'll throw my ass in jail
quick I think it's a major problem like
it's one thing to do drugs and know
about it in the white house it's another
thing to constantly leave them
everywhere
they're not very good I mean Nixon
didn't leave his all over the place
yeah at least you know at least clean up
after yourself there's no cameras in the
White House apparently either the Secret
Service said oh we couldn't figure out
whose cocaine that was so I was
surprised to hear that considering all
the cameras I see in every Federal
Building I've ever worked in I wasn't
surprised to hear it it's the bidens
the the Secret Service was like
Ben Shapiro pointed this out that uh the
Secret Service reportedly went to the
gun shop where Hunter bought his gun and
that was illegally disposed of and tried
to collect records seemingly to protect
the bidens from Criminal prosecution now
I gotta tell you as a Libertarian
that's the most base thing I ever heard
right Hunter being charged with
marijuana and a gun charge second
amendment that that's dope right I I you
know I gotta say
I don't think Hunter Biden should be
charged for owning a weapon there's but
there there's an a fair argument through
due process you can't have your rights
curtailed that's what prison literally
is and if you are found to be a drug
user and we've determined that to be
like hey you know through due process
we've determined you do not have this
right I think there's questions about
whether that should or should be laws or
not that because someone smoked pot one
time they can't have a gun anymore I
don't think that's fair because uh
Hunter had done hard drugs he's
ineligible because someone was committed
to a felony they get out now they can't
get a gun some people have argued well
that's due process and I'm like it's got
to be shorter than that you're right to
vote you're right to keep in bear arms
we shouldn't sentence you to life for it
uh that being said Hunter shouldn't be
charged in my opinion for just buying a
gun oh no for no reason but disposing of
it in a trash can outside of a school
yeah okay you know maybe we got
something there well he's obviously
guilty of something if that's what
you're doing it
was his wife I think his wife did it oh
okay so right
uh did she do it or did she go and get
it what did she go uh no no it was it
was a trash collector who founded uh
okay yeah okay I'm pretty sure it was uh
Hunter's wife
was it am I my wife
I don't know was he ever married I know
he was sleeping with his brother's wife
oh God we need to start such a weird
story it's just so gross like oh yeah
okay okay it's lover they say love her
it was his uh it was his brother's ex
yeah he started hooking up with
Haley or whatever her name is yeah
that's right it is you know like it's
kind of weird though because like they
have the same last name now because she
married her his brother it was kind of a
weird thing you know all the greatest
stuff that when Hollywood ends up making
movies about that family will be about
Hunter and have nothing to do with Joe
at all all the great entertainment will
come out of honey can we can we do who's
done nothing no he was perfect dad
apparently
can we do like a Game of Thrones show
with the bidens yes oh my God it was
beautiful yeah maybe it'd be compelling
you know like you got an episode where
Hunters just like coked out of his mind
and then it shows him like get up and
then he like straightens his jacket and
the bag falls on the ground and then
like some tourist walks by and sees it
and goes no the Secret Service is like
uh-oh and then it probably run like The
Sopranos on HBO no or they they make it
like house of cards with Joe Biden but
it just all keeps happening by accident
nothing actually works out it's just
people are picking up an item it all
keeps happening on accident and
accidentally working out yeah it's
insane like it's it's like accidental
House of Cards Joe Biden trips up the
stairs and then like drops some item
which bounces and then you know like a
marble bounces and then like hits a
button causing a conveyor bounds Saves
the World all yeah right like all these
really weird things happen he's like
he's sitting in the situation room and
they're like quick we need a response
right now Mr President he falls asleep
and then his face hits the keyboard and
it sends the perfect message or just you
know it says yes and they're like yes
and then he averts the crisis things
like that and they can get Kevin Spacey
to play him because he's a great guy too
ew yeah no he'd be perfect for Biden
with all the sniffing you know what I
mean
I think he's done Warden sniffing Kevin
Spacey's on trial right now in the UK
very very bad things
he pulled his own version of of the uh
I'm I'm not a pervert I'm Italian he had
one where he's like I'm a flirt with
like horrible stuff innocent until
proven guilty but uh I'm not giving the
guy the benefit of the doubt we'll see
we'll see you know how it goes I'm a
Flirt yeah also a rapist yes
he's like he's like well like after all
the initial claims came I was like look
I'm gay
yeah and
to do with any of this well now it's
probably a good defense how'd he come
out with it now like this month I mean
oh okay you're good
right it should have worked even then
he'll be like I'm cute yeah I think
maybe he'll maybe he'll work in these
arguments where he's like he couldn't
show Pride events and the behaviors that
people do that are considered normal and
say these things that I was doing were
perfectly in line with what they all do
all day every day at these events nobody
cares about it why am I all of a sudden
being targeted we do live in hell yes
that might be an argument he goes I
don't know but I I did hear that he was
like crying or something yeah
not sure that I care all that much yeah
I mean I don't want to throw the guy uh
you know a safety net or anything but I
mean I I remember a time when when I was
snowboarding in Colorado and if you if
you pulled over on the side of the road
to go to the bathroom and you got caught
you got a sex charge right you could get
like a uh get on a sex registry and now
I mean if you're a q you can just go
piss all over the whole country and you
can get away with it it's just it's just
not I I don't see where all of a sudden
everything is okay yeah so I find it
confusing it's because all the stuff
like it's like when we're talking about
the pride flag everything is about being
oppressed all these groups the one thing
they have in common is they feel they're
oppressed and that's why it's like it's
these degenerate acts that we think of
them as degenerate but then it's like
we're not allowed to do them we don't
have their right so we need to stand up
for those people that don't have the
rights to do all this gross behavior and
that's what we're seeing and it's
completely backwards clown world you
know but it definitely is but that I
mean what you point out about out
there's so many people that have it have
a perspective where they're basing
everything on a
that they're the victim of something
that's something that that's from the
Marxist Playbook the whole point is
power dynamics the whole point is the
person with power is oppressing the
person without power and it all you have
to be able to do is make a compelling
argument that you feel oppressed and
everybody is expected to consent to your
living experience your lived experience
your worldview and you can't have a
society that works like that because
then the incentive is to be oppressed
and to tell everybody about it and we
see the results in society people are
afraid to speak their mind people are
afraid to say things that they believe
people are afraid and they're not afraid
because they have outlandish ideas
they're afraid because the people with
the outlandish ideas are also the ones
that will make us stink and make you
know get people fired or bring you to
the HR department or whatever people
that are unhappy with their lives and
it's all because of that you know the T
teaching people to look at the world
through the dynamic of oppressor and
oppressed and to understand teaching
that them that the position of oppressed
is actually a position of power yeah so
uh did you want to add a point to that I
was just going to say Obama's campaign
was yes we can and it's like no we can't
because of this group or because of this
thing you know that's a fantastic uh
plan for the next Presidential can
campaign no we can no you can't no we
can't so so I wanted to go back to uh uh
when you you someone super chatted us
about AIDS in various populations
considering talking about the flag so I
looked it up and uh 7.7 percent uh uh of
age Global HIV is gay men 7.7 oh well
substantially that was my point I mean I
think in the US maybe the numbers are
different but uh interestingly and this
is from the UN website 10.3 among
transgender persons
very so it's higher interestingly uh I
could be reading this wrong it could
could say that no right I I think that's
that's right yeah the higher prevalence
in these groups to this percentage I
mean once you start to think about why
trans people might be
transmitting diseases I mean it's like
well and stuff they mention
um
people who are injecting things have a
higher prevalence for it so true yes
hormone injections yeah if you're if
hormone yeah I said heroin uh reusing
needles and things like that may result
in its own in the 80s that was a big
part of it no but I just looked it up uh
and so perhaps in the US the numbers are
different but that's why I say I don't
think mostly is the correct term because
it's actually you know what we actually
see with HIV is in many other countries
people of varying demographics and
backgrounds especially a lot of rape
victims too yeah so learn something new
every day wait uh just bring up a
sad subject I suppose cheery well you
know people die Let's uh let's let's
let's wrap up this weekend with
something silly
Politico House GOP plans to hold long
teased UFO hearing that's what it is
about aliens I think people deserve to
know rap Tim Burchette who is leading
effort told Politico great uh Chuck
Schumer is apparently on board or
something you know you know what I think
every time I see these stories
why did Biden do this time yeah exactly
uh heroin was found this time
in the Oval Office that the aliens are
the because this happened they're gonna
last time I was on it was something
about aliens it was like what the hell
are they covering up they're gonna
they're they're gonna find so much so
much drugs that like within three weeks
they're literally staging an alien
invasion and like it's a video of biting
shaking hands with a gray alien and
they're like is it working
yeah
um
excuse me you good there
yeah sorry about that
Oh I thought you're gonna say yeah
made it slit my mind you you were
talking about uh aliens yeah okay so I
was listening to uh a space today uh
musk was on uh talking about AI the new
AI company
um and he was talking about the fact
that he's like look man I haven't seen
anything so all these people like that
are government officials that are like
oh looking at the stuff that the
government said they got man all these
people better know but the dude that
most regularly looks at actual video of
space
probably
in the top 10 people that look at video
space he's like I have seen absolutely
no evidence like like
dead nun zero he says so I I don't know
what the Congress people think they saw
or whatever but I I do find the guy that
actually watches video of Space all the
time I find his opinion compelling as
opposed to freaking Chuck Schumer I'd
rather find out what the lady on the
plane was actually looking at and the
thing that wasn't real I want to know
what she was actually looking at that's
more interesting to me figuring out what
the government thinks about aliens have
they found her yet they have not like
everyone's talking about it and some
people were shaming us into caring
they're like why do you care about this
I'm like because it's the internet
because I'm allowed to care
I was like what should I share with
everyone on the plane yeah but no my
plan was the most boringest thing ever
she had pretty privilege too she was and
she was white so so they haven't found
her we don't know maybe maybe those are
the aliens they're talking about that
the government was talking about they
took her back that's possible that's so
funny she's like he is not real oh yeah
they still haven't found that lady she
disappeared like oh yeah she went
through how has no one figured out of
the person there was progress made today
so a friend of a friend of a friend is
like she's alive and well she went on a
cruise that's why she was on the plane
in the first place drunk don't Ambien
and fly there's we're making progress
we're gonna figure who this is in a day
or two I wanna do we know what happened
she was talking to some dude and I
watched the full video all was like
that dude's not real it was yeah she had
to take an ambient influence she
probably not a good idea what does that
mean not real like is that it like well
she was saying like he made some kind of
remark because I I believe that I I
heard a tick tock of some that someone
was saying I'm the guy so I don't know
that was that was fake I didn't yeah I
didn't check it but he was saying that
like they were talking and he was I
forget where he said he was going but
somehow the conversation went to like
conspiracy theory type stuff and because
she seemed like she was loaded she just
started thinking that he was like a
lizard person or something so I don't
know the details I'm only relating what
I've heard the best was the one where it
says it's the it's the graphic of her
pointing and says that MFR over there is
not real and then it points over there
and it's a picture of Mark Zuckerberg
looking rather reptilian himself in the
photo yeah I'm so sick of these UFO
stories to be honest well it's because
nobody buys them anymore at this point
if aliens came down nobody would care
they're like yeah right oh I'd like to
get on board after this I can't do
another Biden Administration yeah and
not to mention like with the technology
we're seeing now with AI like nothing
you watch on the internet feels real
anymore anyways unless you actually saw
it for yourself in person would you
actually believe that what you were
looking at was real have you guys seen
the new Beavis and butter no I'm gonna
spoil It spoilers because it's relevant
even warned so the I think it's the last
episode of the new season that came out
it's uh a recurring theme and be in the
new one is smart Beavis and smart
Butthead and they're from a parallel
reality where they're super they're
everyone's super intelligent and so they
are super intelligent but still stupid
and so they're instructed to go to Earth
prime or whatever and kidnap someone for
experimentation
they land in this UFO kind of thing and
then they convince that neighbor
whatever his name is and he's just
completely like oh wow look at that and
he walks into the UFO just completely
oblivious I kind of feel like that
that's what I imagine when you're like
at this point of an alien ship land to
be like oh yeah really sure
I would be YouTubers like Jake Paul was
10 years ago
knocking each other out to try and get
inside to get the first clips of inside
the alien spaceship it's actually kind
of crazy to think about
if a spaceship landed in our parking lot
right now and Aliens walked out and we
filmed it nobody would believe it no
they would we would literally post the
video we would start I would live stream
and I would be like guys this is
and they'd be like yeah okay nice try
dude special effects green screen it's a
fake live stream it was pre-loaded
pre-recorded pre-rendered nobody would
believe it no they wouldn't
blame the The Blair Witch Project from
that case so whatever the aliens that
just came like there was I saw a post
about that today like that was like 20
24 years ago today now we're right out
in that area right so yep it happened so
the aliens
specifically seated
CGI technology to us so that we would
have no way to warn anybody about what
was happening so no yeah it's like the
ultimate boy that cried yeah that's
right give them the means to fake
everything they'll fake everything and
then when we invade No One's Gonna buy
it the best brilliant plan the best film
director will get them to work with him
on set so that he doesn't actually have
to use the CGI budget to make the movie
I'm down for that too probably yeah
are there any of the alien stories that
you find more compelling than others no
it's all it's all lies and stupid
nonsense and I'm insulted that they even
bring it up so it's also it is one of
those things now because you live in a
24-hour news cycle that never ends and
if you are acutely aware of what's going
on in the media you look at all of it as
some type of distraction like what is
this taking me away from why are you
pointing over here when I should be
looking over there let's do this let's
say uh has anybody ever how come no one
talks about the uh uh the hole in the
center of the the the followers
I mean why is the UFO and aliens the the
the uh the choice of conspiracy how
about we talk about you know I don't
know dinosaurs super evolved smart cave
dinosaurs because television in The
X-Files made it more palatable in the
90s and it captured the public interest
then so it's the most easy to digest
yeah but every once in a while you'll
get Atlantis talk and some we was Kang
stuff like that you know it doesn't
catch on in the same way no it doesn't
have the same impact because I think
that space is probably something that
everybody is kind of has feels like they
kind of have a connection with because
everyone or at least people that don't
live in cities look up and they see
stars and stuff like that and most
people can see the moon so it's like I
feel like it's compelling to people
whereas like Atlantis is like you got to
be really in the down plus we just had
that whole Ocean Gate thing nobody wants
to get on the bottom of the ocean
anymore not for a while oh that's what
happens
people down there we were watching some
somebody downstairs was watching some
Flat Earth video and I just
groan listening to Flat Earth people
because it's like this guy going like I
don't have any definitive statements I
just have theories round earth is a
theory and Flat Earth is a theory and
it's like you can't prove it and I'm
just like oh they actually let me tell
you they they really have come far on
the whole proving it part but my
favorite is when they go how come no
one's allowed to go to Antarctica and
I'm like I know people who've gone there
you come
you can bid this and they go how come
you can't fly over the North Pole like
dude I literally did when I flew from
New York to Hong Kong yeah I don't
understand where they just make this
stuff up it's infuriating and then they
all just keep repeating it like nobody
like I love this video where this guy
does this thing where they he's like I'm
gonna prove that the Earth is flat or
whatever and he he's like he's like if
the Earth is round then if you cut if
you take two boards and cut holes in
them and then shine a light through it
the camera should be able to pick up the
light
if it's round you won't be able to
because the curvature of the earth it'll
be you have to raise the camera up and
if it's flat it should be perfectly even
and sure enough he's like wait a minute
wait wait hold on there a minute like
what's happening I can't see the light
it's like raise it up and he does and he
sees the lights like oh accidentally
confirming the experiments about proving
the Earth is round but the crazy thing
to me is that people say insane things
like you can't go to Antarctica because
they're like it's the firmament it's the
boundary that surrounds the disc Earth
or whatever and I'm like dude you can
literally go to Antarctica it's
expensive there's nothing there and so
the average thing people do is They Ride
you hit you get to take it on a cargo
ship they know that Metallica played
there right that actually happened
Metallica is the only band that is
played on all seven conspiracy they
think it's a conspiracy
that you you buy a ticket as a regular
tourist and they that you get a few
hours on Antarctica because what else
you're gonna do gonna go die but there
are people with more money it means that
prepare Expeditions and literally just
go and explore Antarctica I just
people will say a thing and then
everyone just says it's true I believe
it and they just go along with it I've
heard that the reason that they don't
have uh flights that go over the South
Pole is because that part of the earth
is very remote like if you go over the
North Pole you like you're over Canada
you're you know there's all kinds of
cities all in in the vicinity but like
the South Pole it's really remote so
they're just like you know have them go
there's no reason to look the reason
you'd fly over the North Pole is because
going from New York to Hong Kong it is
faster to go straight point to point the
idea would be that you'd fly all the way
over Russia or all the way over the
Pacific to try and get to Hong Kong just
go right over because it's it's a sphere
that makes sense the South Pole makes no
sense because what do you do fly from
Chile and then loop around and go to
like yeah Australia that makes no sense
the distances are Florida down there
most of the population lives in the the
global North you know Asia and and North
America like there there's Africa and
South America but like most of the the
population on on Earth is above the
equator you know we're gonna go to Super
Chat so if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share this show with
your friends and become a member at
timcast.com to support our work directly
and uh we will read these we do members
only shows Monday through Thursday
nothing today and uh just a quick
reminder I I will we will have a guest
host all next week Seamus oh boy of
Freedom Tunes
um grateful that he is able to do it
because
gotta go to the doctor but uh here's
Raymond g Stanley Jr and the Super Chat
saying Tim sir my guy yesterday holy
moly what a feel-good moment that was
watching the super chats roll in
everyone deserves a shout out the
viewers the staff the cast yourself for
the line
so basically what happens is at the end
of the show I'm like if you someone said
give the super chats to Tim Ballard I
said okay and then we start seeing you
know 10 20 come in and I'm like you know
what that makes no sense like I'll just
double it and then within a few minutes
the couple Grand I thought I was going
to be writing a check for turned into
twenty four thousand dollars and I was
like well here we go wow I didn't expect
that but it was really really incredible
to see everybody pitch in and if you
guys can I can I really do appreciate
your support and uh I think it's cool
that together we did this for Tim Bell's
new organization which he just launched
so hopefully this fifty thousand dollar
check will be a huge uh kick in the butt
for the start of his organization to get
to get it going quickly I also saw
something earlier that somebody said
that the the organization website he was
listing was like he was saying the spear
like he was saying it wrong somebody
bought it and then said how can we give
this to him to make sure that the one
that he was mentioning on the show was
the one that actually redirected to the
to the actual website so that's an even
better it's another great example of
everybody coming together
spearfund.org redirect suicides coming
soon he just announced it but I hope
that uh together we each were able to
put up uh 25k you the audience and and
me and I gotta be honest the money for
me is basically still money from you
guys as viewers and his members so I'm
grateful to be able to help him get that
going because man
yesterday was something else what an
amazing conversation
let's grab some more Super chats
what do we have here rafty says agreed
Raymond uh Stanley Jr YouTube is
blocking the gentle agreement I want to
share with everyone like a reminder of
the link to the site for free tickets oh
you can't link it it's uh what was the
it it's Angel dot what is it angel.com
what's the pay it forward link I mean
Angel
studiosangel.com paid Dash it Dash
forward but I think you just go to
angel.angelsangel.com you should be able
to find it's probably easier to find it
that way so not only do we do we do 50k
I bought 750 theater tickets at uh
eleven thousand five hundred dollars so
that uh more people can go see this film
I want to win this culture where man I
want to build a parallel economy I want
to see these Studios succeed I want to
see new movies come out and I want to
help save kids
it's a fantastic example like if you're
looking for a white pill for how things
are coming I want to see the movie
theater was packed everybody that we've
talked to on our podcast everyone that's
super chatted talking about the movie
has said that when they've gone to the
theater the theater was packed for them
as well so that is a fantastic sign
someone was saying that Jewel was
talking about the movie she was yeah
awesome she's uh she knows the people
like she knew the producers and she knew
people involved with the production of
the movie she's on uh on Concord which
is my my previous label the label that I
was on before we oh right on yeah so
should hit her up have her come out
that'd be really cool actually was
that's why I found out that she's on
Concord you know oh right on no where
who's our management I'm gonna see if I
can reach out that'd be really cool I'll
try she has a bunch of those big 90s
hits right like a great song and like
she and she's been working consistently
so as much as like what happens in the
music industry a lot of times people
come out and they'll have whatever puts
them on the map that gives them heat and
then kind of like people get used to
them there they build their fan base and
like the people that are just like into
the one song kind of will go back to
doing their thing or finding other stuff
but they they have like uh but she
really built a fan base that's really
kept her her relevant for a long time
she's been uh she's been working yeah
ages that'd be cool to talk to everybody
Seth Essington says why does Brett never
wear his glasses on IRL
um the the lights
too bright too bright in here both the
glasses and it's like the it's the end
of the day and I'm just yeah yep Eric
Miller says Tim next week why don't you
call in through Discord so you can still
be part of the conversation perhaps what
I can do is just hang out in the Discord
but uh the reality is I'm going to be
literally in a hospital all week so uh
here's the gist of it uh I have probably
a labrum hip tear cartilage damage which
reduces mobility and range of motion and
causes pain when uh I'm extending my leg
and so if I were to pursue your typical
course of treatment what I was told by
the local hospitals was we can consult
you in two weeks okay well I can't I
can't skate so like what do I do what am
I I can't exercise like that's no good
we're we're currently working on
building the facility which includes
skating and exercise and I want to be
able to do it after the consultation
we'll perhaps schedule in a few days
over the weekend of course so it could
be four or five days an MRI okay and
then from there we'll plan out in the
next couple of months a procedure for
which we can start to prepare I'm like
okay you know what man so there is a
facility that uh is out of state it's
one of the highest rated like sports
injury clinics and they're like we do it
all in a week you come in
all the all the diagnostic work then we
prepare then we we Wednesday we we plan
the treatment and then you should be
done with everything by Friday the the
reality with the labrum tear treatments
they do uh PRP and stem cells that's
platelet platelet-rich plasma but they
can also do surgical repairs these only
take like an hour but you have to go
through like paperwork MRI diagnosis so
I'm like this this one place will do it
all right away done done but it means
I'm basically in the hospital going
through the whole process that's it so
there's no Morning Show I can't do IRL
but it beats randomly taking off one or
two nights every week to go through this
and then not being able to skate or
exercise for six seven months because
then the recovery process because
they're saying recovery for it could be
like a
a month to two months and I will also
add this it's so annoying because like I
can run up and down the stairs I can
jump I can basically do literally
everything except kickflip
I can't do it like anything that
requires a Ninja Kick of my left leg
it's just like there's there's no
strength yeah and so the general uh what
I'm generally told by the doctors is
if you don't take care of it now
and you keep going hip replacement later
my shoulder replaced it sucked right uh
so they're like we can do something
that's minimally invasive it's going to
take a week of your time it's done in an
hour takes you a month and then you're
good or you can ignore it be in pain not
exercise and then in a few years or so
have to deal with a real serious
invasive surgery so it's just like let's
just do it let's just get it over with
I'm an old man so it has to be done and
with less exercise in the meantime it
actually makes the problem worse the
longer it goes exactly but uh I'm still
having like reoccurring knee issues
that's one of those things like when I
was skating every single day I was I
just built up enough strength that I was
able to get through it without having
too many problems but since then like
even now if I'm skating just three four
times a week uh I notice it way more uh
you know it's not like I'm working
manual labor so it's like if I go out
and try and skate at 8 pm or 9 pm when
I'm done with work I feel as if I've
been you know it feels as if I've been
on my feet the whole day when that's not
necessarily the case because I'm not
building up the the strength from
skating every single day
yeah so anyway uh that means I'm out I'm
out and uh I hate doing it it'll be like
there's only one other one other time
that an injury ended up resulting in me
not being able to work and it was a I
got a root canal no uh no I got a crown
put on I got a crown put on uh I I had a
root canal a long time ago and I had to
get it fixed and that was three days of
Mike
uh I think I still remember that that's
before that was like 2018 or something I
still remember the post about it because
I was watching the show at the time and
it's just like segments I hate that I
was sick a week ago and now it's like
this thing happens and I'm just like you
know as my body begins to fall apart and
I age and uh with her away that's just
the reality of it right
all right yeah 37. oh my God
you talk like you're 51. yeah I know I'm
kidding I'm kidding I'm mostly kidding
and it's because like outside of the the
hip thing I don't notice that like I
don't notice anything about being 37
when I skate except my hips started to
hurt and I'm like there it is that's
literally just it knees are fine jump
strength everything seems to be fine
actually doing New Tricks better tricks
and then you know after 23 or so years
of skating you get some damage in your
cartilage it's not healing and now
you're you go to the hospital all right
the KL tanker says Sheamus should not
get a coffee blend it should be hot
chocolate with Lucky Charms marshmallows
perfect actually we had a really good
idea for Sheamus's uh blend but I don't
want to say anything just yet
of course that'll actually take some
time but the uh the new ones are are
almost ready that
Mr boca's pumpkin spice experience and
the K-Cups should be available very very
soon so
all right
vasht says this is literally MSM saying
Trump called neo-nazi's very fine people
I stand on principle F Pence and F fake
news voting Vivek
you know the the issue is what I get out
of what Mike Pence said when he was like
that's not my concern I think it's fair
to say he was trying to say Ukraine was
not my concern but then he literally
says why can't it be our concern yeah he
says if you think it can't be one of our
one of the issues we care about then
you're mistaken so where are we at with
it halfway he didn't say screw American
cities
he didn't say all for Ukraine and
nothing else
he said no look it you know Ukraine
isn't my concern America isn't and doing
right by America but we can be leaders
of the Free World too and I'm like so
the the truth is closer to the middle
yeah some people may say I don't care
about Ukraine put your all your focus
don't waste time and his argument is we
can do both
we can be we can we can help Ukraine and
help America I don't know about that
dude the government here continually
proves that they cannot do both they can
rarely do one
Andrew just my biggest problem with it
with the whole Ukraine thing is that
like I said to a friend today regardless
of what the details are about the new
issue I still don't see the off ramp I
don't see what gets us out of a you know
out of the confrontation with Russia yet
and until I do I'm just well we're just
shipping over more weapons of mass
destruction I mean stuff that have been
banned cluster munitions
and it's going to escalate because they
they had criticized Russia for doing the
same thing now the US and the West is
doing it yeah now troops Reserve troops
being sent to Europe come on we've got
they've got you've you've got both the
Russian and Ukrainian soldiers don't
want to be fighting this war you know
what I'm looking forward to I just want
to imagine this so uh you're sitting on
the sidewalk
sitting up against a brick wall
that is nothing but rubble and the power
lines have crashed down the sky is
orange and uh there's there's just
buildings collapsed everywhere and
you're covered in dirt and you're
shaking and then you see is the best
part a liberal walks by and you get to
go
so
it'll be so worth it won't it
I was telling someone at the castle that
like when we had all that smoke from the
Canadian wildfires I'm like if we had
like a nuclear like War this is how it
would be every day so if we survived the
blast it would just be this Haze we
can't breathe be terrible it'd be awful
Andrew Roland says if we elect Vivek we
Republicans get bragging rights to elect
the first Native American president thus
taking off the left since they are
obsessed with the first this and that
isn't viveka uh Indian
yeah I think so but not Native American
no no no yeah I think he's uh Indian
tree that's right I say the party switch
later and then they'll take credit for
it won't matter yeah
what do we have here in the old super
chat box
Ryan Ellis says politicians will use our
tax dollars to supply guns and ammo to
foreigners they will also use our tax
dollars to pass legislation that bans
Americans from owning guns and ammo the
same guns they say are evil and have no
place in society weapons of war yup yes
we've armed every enemy we've ever had
here's uh here's a question for you
Andrew reinheimer says question for
Shannon how are your positions better
than Mark Robinson
oh that's in North Carolina
um it well it kind of depends on what
we're talking about whether it's uh the
education the economy
um or even the social issues uh Mark
Robinson is fairly authoritarian uh very
hard to the right there's some things
that we agree on like the abolishment of
Obamacare and you know trying to help
some of the health care
um but I'm also I have some differences
on the abortion aspects to where I too
would like to see a 12 to 16 week
abortion
ban after but with the exception of
medical conditions that that are there
to save you know the mom's life and and
the baby's life where he's more he's
more negative
um on a lot of those aspects so and
um he's a very hard right Republican
um a lot of people are having you know a
hard time stomaching a lot of his
policies
um but then my one of my goals is to go
after taxes and reduce the size of the
government in in North Carolina which is
going after the Department of Education
or not just education but our education
system there is is horrendous I mean we
get the
um
the north education or the North
Carolina Education Lottery which is
really the only money that's going to
our education system yet we're 50th in
the country what state has the has the
best education system in the country
right now
does anybody know why it is like who
like if you were to model your education
department after after one what would
you be looking to do for it that that
that's actually an excellent question I
probably need to look at who's who's
number one Florida not in terms of like
outside of the uh academic approach but
in terms of the parental rights and
cultural approach yeah Rhonda Sanders
did a pretty good job I'm a big fan of
the whole school choice and um the
parents being involved and you know in
North Carolina we didn't really we don't
really have that we're last but yet we
um the government is just uh
it's horrendous in education so I mean I
moved away from Louisiana because they
had the worst education system when I
was growing up and I moved to North
Carolina and now we're the worst so I
just followed you it just followed me
around
all right we'll grab this one Chuck
Taylor says for Phil what was it like
working with Shannon Lucas he's my
all-time favorite love all the remains
saw you guys at hob Cleveland and 07 but
not since oh wow sick well uh Shannon's
great
um at the time you know we were we were
both really young and uh so we could
only kind of make it work for one record
but we've since uh talked and and I'm
hoping that Shannon will do something
for All That Remains uh in the future
not like recording or anything but we
talked about getting him to do some drum
playthroughs of stuff that he did on the
fall uh the fall of ideals and uh
hopefully we can get him to do that so
keep your eyes out cheers
all right JR says Libertarians tend to
suffer the no true Scotsman fallacy a
lot
yeah yep
Bruno bronowski says Tim why aren't you
posting videos to twitter yet stop being
a bonus hole I love you brother and he
and he switched at that four times I
think that might have been an accident
uh we actually are discussing that the
challenge is I'm not sure a 20-minute
segment would do as well on Twitter as
it does on YouTube because YouTube is a
platform where you open the the player
and then work and listen Twitter is
you're scrolling through
there is the potential now I mean Elon
is doing an amazing job mad props the
picture in picture for videos
it was brilliant that that does open the
door I think what we're looking at right
now is uploading short clips but
typically about a minute long and then
you know linking to a longer form thing
or something like that I think for what
Twitter is shorter form video would do
really well to ignite conversation and
generate plus uh because if if I put up
a 20 minute video on Twitter someone's
10 minutes through and then they say oh
I'm gonna comment on that and then they
reply yeah you said Trump did this and
he did that that's what I think someone
else is going to see that comment and be
like I didn't hear that part like where
where in the video is that part right
because Twitter is very different yeah
but you know to be completely honest
it's a it's about experimenting and I
think one of the things we're looking at
is potentially simulcasting to Twitter
uh mainly because I'll say I know this
the majority of people who follow me on
Twitter do not watch this show live
they'll watch Clips or something like
that and that if we did put up our show
live 8pm on Twitter I think we'd end up
getting like 10 to 20 million more views
than we already do and so I I think
probably by the time I'm back I'm hoping
that we've we figure out how we can do
that effectively uh and the monetization
is a huge element of it the Tucker's
doing pretty good on Twitter
yeah and and uh he's been getting like
he got what like 70 100 million views or
whatever yeah and you know Elon says how
many Impressions do you generate is how
much you get paid you know the reality
is Tucker is generating a lot of AD
Impressions when he's getting 50 million
views in a video so I I genuinely think
uh it's hard to know for sure exactly
what would happen if we went live on
Twitter I know a lot of people who
follow me on Twitter do not watch live
on YouTube I know a lot of people really
don't like YouTube but don't want to be
here but they are on Twitter because
they got unbanned and so I wonder I mean
I've seen a lot of people do live
streams on Twitter to very little
success yeah I wonder if we would have
the same degree of success but to be
fair I also have 1.7 million followers
on Twitter so maybe we would end up
getting a million or so hits and that's
really enough I mean to be completely
honest so we'll see I think one thing
that Elon needs to do
is he needs a grid format for videos and
when it comes to live you need real-time
comments not just thread comments so
chat like a similar to the chat function
yup yup yup and uh I hope it gets there
but uh either way you know I we're
interested in trying to uh uh multicast
Simon I wonder if you if you tweet while
you're watching a video if they could
just put a time stamp in the uh in the
Tweet yeah just to reference where they
where you said in the video but real
time chat matters yeah you know like
when you re-watch these shows you can
see the real-time chat so because the
someone's comment goes along with right
where the video is and like you can see
that happen that's an interaction that
matters like we when we do live like
I'll interact actually like pretty
extensively with people in the chat as
well not just like the super chats but
like if somebody makes a reference point
or I'll ask the chat for like like
verify on this right here so if you're
watching back and if you're watching the
playthrough that won't make sense unless
you also follow the live chat replay
along so
right on
does the is it possible like do you have
a hard time seeing the way that like
YouTube shorts does that transition more
to to viewership in a way
I think YouTube shorts Drive subscribers
yeah and younger people tend to use them
but uh it's crazy the amount of views
we're getting on shorts is is ridiculous
but it's not worth any money though no
it's it makes very very little in the
way of money but a lot of it but if it's
advertising and it gets people that
might not normally engage with the
content because if you're if people are
watching or used to more long-form
content especially like like this show
or our show is a two-hour podcast every
day that's very different than somebody
who's literally going and scrolling and
looking for YouTube shorts so sometimes
you'll actually it's kind of interesting
you'll get people that are more uh that
disagree with you more because they're
looking for different content and
they're not in the same like in the same
sphere of influence so you get a lot of
people that end up pushing back on the
stuff you say which is awesome all right
let's grab a Super Chat atherin zala
says Tim here's how you prove the world
is round if it was flat cats would have
knocked everything off the edge fair
fair that's that's true compelling I
love I was reading about this and uh I
was reading this post from a flat Earth
gravity is not real
what actually is happening is that the
Earth is accelerating infinitely upwards
which creates
every time a turtle appears underneath
which is constantly happening that's
pushing the Earth up because it's
Turtles well no it's just you know the
the image was it's not it's not flat
it's more of like a disc with like rocks
underneath it like hanging and then
rushing through space and it's rushing
through space
exponentially increasing in speed which
simulates gravity because of this if it
was going the same speed you would not
experience gravity you'd you'd be in you
know like stasis with plants so it has
to be going faster I'm just like dude or
gravity like Israel I don't know man
yeah they wasted their brain cells on
that theory you know but they try
Justice skeptic says the best thing you
said tonight Tim was about the potheads
it's true I'll have to go back and play
it later from a pothead
well right on you know I I don't think
people shouldn't be allowed to but I
just think it is it is not good
Solon Woodall says the smell of cast
brew coffee is one of the world's
greatest inventions
indeed uh I'm gonna say it again because
every morning when we had I I've been
having Appalachian nights I just can't
wrap my head around like how did how
does this so good
we got a bunch of beans we we tried
mixing different kinds I wanted a little
darker roast and like we hit this blend
that was so good I'm just
I'm not kidding I love that stuff
I could just like drink like a gallon of
it in the morning
we will grab some super chats here we
got sideways saying man I think Ian
might have been right about Ron and
Vivek switching spots they don't always
agree with him but he rolled a 20 on
that one for sure
yeah I think um
I think
maybe in a couple weeks a couple months
vivek's going to be number two
he's hitting it out of the park you know
and unfortunately for Ron I think the
issue is he's got great policy but the
the hatred towards him comes from a
perceived disloyalty that he went
against Trump that he was saying he's
he's not going to run and then all of a
sudden it was like all in the cards the
whole time I think people are pissed
about that
but also it's probably that
to a certain degree nobody really thinks
Vivek is going to win
right no no but what if Trump actually
gets indicted for something right and
then you lose that power base then all
of a sudden you have an election in
turmoil he's already been indicted well
I mean actually convicted convicted yeah
that would be
absolute chaos
God's other son says I've had hip issues
for almost 30 years they eventually
recruited my knees in their war against
me get better soon
yeah my knees are seem to be pretty good
um I should by all accounts have
legs that shake and I can barely stand
because I've been skating for 23 years
sprained and roll I rolled my ankle on
dozens upon dozens of times my knees
should be they they make a disgusting
sound when I bend them because you know
just what I've been doing my whole life
but uh no issues whatsoever there you
know like I'm skating and uh for the
skate nerds out there we we went up to
film and I was like I'm gonna do a
nollie flip no slide on the ledge which
is you know I guess it's a decently good
trick and I lock it in first try and
slip out
and what I encountered when trying that
we were filming is that I can't extend
my left leg enough when I snap when I
pop the board and it's causing me
problems and pain and I thought it would
just go away I'm like I must have
strained it or something it did not it
got worse and so I reached out to some
pro athletes and I was just like what do
you think and they're like oh bro dude
whoa no I know this I've heard the story
before you like you need to call doctor
and I was like okay and then they were
just like
20 30 years ago they'd say to you they'd
say well life's like life sucks uh take
some ibuprofen and good luck but now
we've got all these treatments and
they're like no no get it in now we'll
take care of it you'll be good as new
that's the reality of the world man I
gotta I gotta go and it won't be the
first time it won't be it's not it it
actually is the first time actually I
guess if you count the uh the crown I
got but it won't be the last time I'm
only getting older nothing can do about
it it'll happen and uh say la vie but I
do think the important component here is
all of you have been begging that we get
uh um Reserve hosts backup hosts and
other co-hosts who can take over the
show and host it on in events I'm
incapacitated so the show doesn't just
cease to exist and in fact that's
actually why Phil's here and potentially
in the future uh Phil will be doing the
same thing Sheamus is doing while we
have Sheamus Sheamus can can handle it
but uh even you know Phil at some point
and then um
it's got to be more than just me in the
long run so we've got Morning Show plans
a view like show studio is at like
I think maybe like 70 completion
construction cylinder way some hiccups
along the way but uh it's it's common it
just takes a really long time to build
this all and then once the new
facility's up we're going to be doing a
Morning Show to compete with the view
with sane women
it's gonna be very fun I'm excited about
that especially considering the ladies
that were that you've been talking about
having on there I think it's gonna be a
lot of fun yeah it's people everyone
knows knows and loves people we've had
on the uh on the show before that are
moms that have a moderate to like
reasonable view of varying dispositions
conservative liberal Libertarians I say
this with deep love for all of them
they're all big mouth it's gonna be
hilarious
hilarious a fill in the morning show
where you just yell at everyone in the
morning I probably can do that but uh I
I would wake you up I would rather hear
the ladies because they're gonna be I'm
telling you it's gonna be great
but we're doing as much as we can so uh
we'll we'll grab one more Super Chat
here
uh what do we have what's what's a
what's a good one
oh Liddy says Tim you should all shroom
for one video during the day and in the
wilderness Ian was right it's great well
I always tell people to consult their
doctors there has been a tremendous
breakthrough in research pertaining to
uh you know PTSD and Trauma and
psilocybin things like that but that's
where a doctor to decide and it is it is
fair to say I believe recreational it's
legal in some states so make sure you're
always abiding by the law and talk to a
medical professional about what's right
for you you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast we may be posting clips from
the show on that uh Twitter account I
think it's extremely likely within the
next week or so and uh smash the like
button subscribe to this channel I am
out all next week but uh Sheamus has you
we have a bunch of really really great
guests
um this is really abrupt and it was an
opportunity to just try and get this uh
this this hip thing done right away so I
really do appreciate everybody as
members at timcast.com you've afforded
me the ability to take a sick day
something I had not experienced for for
a very long time if I didn't work I
didn't make money but you guys as
members have uh given me that gift I
really do appreciate it Shannon do you
want to shout anything out oh yeah I
mean uh thanks thanks for having me and
uh if uh if anyone wants to read any
policies or whatever you can find out on
shannonbrae.us
um or really to kind of discuss anything
I'm fairly active on social media so uh
Shannon Bray and C on Twitter
um and uh I'm happy to to chat right on
thanks for coming I am Phil Labonte I am
Phil that remains on Twitter and Philip
remains official on Instagram uh the
band is All That Remains were available
on Spotify Apple music uh Pandora the
old YouTube uh next week I'm gonna be in
La uh doing drums for some upcoming
releases that we have planned and uh if
you follow me on Twitter you'll see some
updates for that
guys my name is Brett dasovic it's at
Brett dasovic on Twitter and on
Instagram pop culture crisis is Monday
through Friday 3 P.M Eastern Standard
Time that is noon Pacific you should
come join us it's a lot of fun
and I am Kellen you guys can follow me
at Kellen PDL uh I press the buttons on
Fridays and uh it was a good great great
show it was a lot of fun so thanks guys
thanks for hanging out everybody I'll
also I recommend checking out the
culture War episode from this morning at
youtube.com timcast debating the issue
of should uh is drag appropriate for
children and I wanna I just want to
address something for a lot of people
it's a it's a mixed bag of comments some
people are like Tim wow you did a really
great job letting this person speak and
share all their ideas we need to know
what they're thinking and other people
being like Tim why didn't you push back
and yell the culture War show has had
its moments of me arguing with people
but we're really trying to have other
people Express their ideas and have that
conversation so what I'm hoping with the
show is to get people to explain their
ideas so that you can hear them and then
ask them questions and explore in a
somewhat Socratic method what they're
really thinking and it does lead to
contradictions some episodes will be
better than others but it we're really
trying to make sure that it's not just
me arguing with someone it is two people
of different ideas discussing it and so
that was the plan uh that being said I
will wrap it up here thank you all so
much for hanging out and uh you'll see
you'll see Sheamus next week